I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Get out your snorkels.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，也是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好！拿好你们的呼吸管。
Uh, I am so excited today. I loved this episode in the rewatch. It was so fun and we have so many fun people who are going to share memories from this episode. I say let's get into it. I'm excited. Well, before we get started, we have some morning announcements. Did you have morning announcements in school? Like, did a person come on the intercom
呃，我今天太兴奋了。重温时我超爱这一集。它太有趣了，而且有这么多好玩的人来分享这一集的记忆。我说我们开始吧。我很兴奋。好吧，在我们开始之前，我们要播报一些晨间公告。你们上学时有晨间公告吗？比如，有人会通过对讲机
and give you morning announcements? Yes. Me too! Me too! I think they still do it. I think they're still morning announcements. We had this thing when I was a senior in high school where the seniors got to take over the morning announcements for a week. I know, it was like a big fun thing. All right, well, I'm gonna do my best at a morning announcement. This is really exciting.
播报晨间公告吗？有。我也是！我也是！我想他们现在还在做这事。我觉得现在依然有晨间公告。我读高三时，学校有个规定，高三学生可以接管一周的晨间公告。我知道，这就像是一件非常有趣的大事。好吧，那我要尽力播报一次晨间公告。这真的让人很兴奋。
We now have signed copies of our book, The Office BFFs, Available for pre-order. They are online right now at the following retailers, Barnes & Noble, Books a Million, BJ's wholesalers, and Premier Collectibles, and you can support independent bookstores by purchasing a signed copy at Strand Bookstore. You guys, Jenna and I signed thousands of copies of books, boxes and boxes of these sheets of paper that were pages from our book that they bind into the book. Yes, and I mean our families, I feel like they were like, what are you signing more? Okay, are you signing more? What are you doing? Oh, you're signing more? Like that was like the narrative for weeks. I set up a little TV tray by our TV in our our family room. And when we would watch a movie, I would just all you would hear in the background was a sharp
我们的书《办公室闺蜜》（The Office BFFs）的签名版现已开启预售。它们目前在以下零售商的网站上有售：巴诺书店（Barnes & Noble）、Books a Million、BJ's 批发俱乐部以及 Premier Collectibles，你也可以通过在 Strand 书店购买签名版来支持独立书店。各位，珍娜和我签了数千本书，一箱又一箱的书页纸，这些都是从我们的书中拆下来的纸张，之后会被装订进书里。是的，我是说我们的家人，我觉得他们当时都在想：“怎么还在签？好吧，你们还在签？你们在干嘛？哦，又要签了？”好像连续好几个星期，大家都在讨论这事。我在我们家庭室的电视机旁放了一个小电视托盘。每当我们看电影时，你唯一能在背景里听到的声音就是沙沙的笔
be going, it took me two months to sign all of these. Yes. This was a big project. Yeah. But they're out there. They are available. You can find a link on our officeladies.com website. We're going to put it up on our socials. And you can also find it at hc.com slash office BFFs. We sign them with love, you guys. We sign them with love. We did.
尖声，我花了两个月才把这些全签完。是的。这是一个大工程。是的。但它们已经推出了。它们现在都有售。你可以在我们的网站 officeladies.com 上找到链接。我们也会把它发到社交媒体上。你还可以在 hc.com slash office BFFs 上找到它。我们是用爱签名的，各位。我们是用爱签名的。真的。
Okay, morning announcements are done. Let's get in to this episode. Today we are breaking down Koi Pond. It is season six, episode eight, written by Warren Lieberstein and Hallstead Sullivan and directed by Reggie Huddlin. Here is your summary. It's very simple. It really is. Here is your summary. It's very simple. It really is. But it packs a big splash. Woo! Michael falls into a koi pond
好了，晨间公告播完啦。让我们进入这一集。今天我们要剖析的是《锦鲤池》（Koi Pond）。这是第六季第八集，由沃伦·利伯斯坦（Warren Lieberstein）和霍尔斯特德·沙利文（Halstead Sullivan）编剧，雷吉·哈德林（Reggie Huddlin）执导。以下是你的剧情简介。非常简单。确实如此。以下是你的剧情简介。非常简单。确实如此。但它能溅起巨大的水花。哇！迈克尔掉进了锦鲤池
while out for a meeting and becomes the butt of many office jokes. Meanwhile, Pam and Andy go out on mandated cold calls and are mistaken for a married couple all day. A married couple expecting a baby. A very funny runner, I enjoyed it. Fast Fact Number One.
在出门开会时掉进去的，并成了办公室许多笑话的笑柄。与此同时，潘和安迪奉命去进行冷拜访，结果整整一天都被误认为是一对已婚夫妇。一对即将迎来宝宝的已婚夫妇。一个非常搞笑的连贯小笑料，我很喜欢。第一条幕后快讯。
This episode was directed by legend Reggie Hudlin. You know, it happened from time to time on the office when we would get these directors that you just can't believe that they are directing your television show. Yeah. And Reggie was one of them. So Reggie wrote and directed the film House Party. He directed the film Boomerang. He directed 11 episodes of the Bernie Mac show. He was the president of Black Entertainment Television for three years. And he went on to be a producer on Quentin Tarantino's Django Unchained, which was nominated for Best Picture at the Academy Awards. Reggie was amazing to work with.
这一集由传奇导演雷吉·哈德林执导。你知道，在《办公室》拍摄期间，有时我们会遇到一些导演，让你简直不敢相信他们在执导你的电视剧。是的。雷吉就是其中之一。所以雷吉编剧并执导了电影《派对屋》（House Party）。他执导了电影《回马枪》（Boomerang）。他执导了11集的《伯尼·麦克秀》（The Bernie Mac Show）。他曾担任黑人娱乐电视台（Black Entertainment Television）的总裁三年。后来他还担任了昆汀·塔伦蒂诺的《被解救的姜戈》（Django Unchained）的制片人，该片曾获奥斯卡最佳影片提名。和雷吉合作太棒了。
He was just great. And in addition to all of his professional accomplishments, his family history is amazing. I knew a little bit of it, but I didn't know everything. In researching this episode, I went to his website and his bio, his family bio is worth a read. I will give you the highlights. His family grew up in East St. Louis. His great-great-grandparents were Peter and Nancy Hudlin who were part of the Underground Railroad.
他简直太棒了。除了他所有的职业成就之外，他的家族史也极为惊人。我之前略知一二，但并不完全了解。在为这一集做资料收集时，我访问了他的网站，他的个人简介，也就是他的家族简介，非常值得一读。我给你们讲讲其中的亮点。他的家族在东圣路易斯长大。他的曾祖父母是彼得和南茜·哈德林（Peter and Nancy Hudlin），他们曾是地下铁路（Underground Railroad）的参与者。
His great-uncle was a very famous Tennyson instructor who mentored Arthur Ash and Althea Gibson. Regia Tendred Harbor University where he graduated graduated magna cum laude with a BA in visual and an environmental studies, and it was at Harvard that he directed his thesis project, which was a short film version of House Party. It was inspired by his experience growing up in East St. Louis, and that short film became the basis of his feature film, House Party. Well, we reached out to Warren and Hallstead, the writers of his feature film, House Party. Well, we reached out to Warren and Halstead, the writers of this episode. They are going to share awesome, awesome stuff with us.
他的叔公是一位非常著名的网球教练，曾指导过亚瑟·阿什（Arthur Ash）和阿尔西娅·吉布森（Althea Gibson）。雷吉就读于哈佛大学，并以优异成绩（magna cum laude）获得视觉与环境研究文学学士学位，正是在哈佛，他执导了他的毕业论文项目——电影《派对屋》的短片版本。这灵感来自于他在东圣路易斯长大的经历，而那部短片成为了他后来拍摄的长片《派对屋》的基础。我们联系了沃伦和霍尔斯特德，这部长片的编剧……哦，我们联系了沃伦和霍尔斯特德，这一集的编剧。他们将与我们分享超棒超棒的内容。
We can't wait to share with you. Warren said that one of the perks of writing on the office was being able to meet some of the people in the industry. You really admired. He was a big fan of House Party and Boomerang. So he was thrilled Reggie was going to direct the episode. And he said Reggie was quote all class and we had a great week together. It was an honor working with him. Yeah. And Halstead also mentioned working with Reggie when we reached out. And he just said that Reggie had an amazing sense of humor and he knew how to land the jokes. He also said that Reggie was a great storyteller.
我们迫不及待地想与大家分享。沃伦说，在《办公室》编剧的好处之一，就是能够结识一些你在业内非常崇拜的人。他是《派对屋》和《回马枪》的超级粉丝。所以当得知雷吉要来执导这一集时，他激动不已。他说雷吉简直是“风度翩翩，无可挑剔”，我们度过了非常棒的一周。能与他合作是我的荣幸。是的。当我们联系霍尔斯特德时，他也提到了与雷吉合作的经历。他说雷吉有着惊人的幽默感，并且深知如何让笑话产生效果。他还说雷吉是一位极佳的故事讲述者。
He said he doesn't think he told stories with the intention of Holstead repeating any of them on a podcast, but he just wanted to say that he was really great to work with and he'd really like to work with him again. I feel the same way. I mean, I just have wonderful memories of doing this episode. Same. All right. Now for FastFact number two, Ange. Warren shared with us that there was a very, very unique writing style for this episode, and I found it totally fascinating. He said that with most episodes of the office, and including most shows he's ever worked on, they lay out
他说，他觉得雷吉讲故事时并不是为了让霍尔斯特德在播客上复述这些故事，但他只是想说，与雷吉合作真的非常棒，他非常希望能再次与他合作。我也有同感。我是说，关于拍这一集，我只有美好的回忆。我也是。好了，接下来是第二条幕后快讯，安吉拉。沃伦跟我们分享说，这一集的写作风格非常非常独特，我发现这完全令人着迷。他说，对于《办公室》的大多数剧集，包括他参与过的大多数节目，他们都会在
this story on index cards, which we've talked about. You love the index cards on the wall of the writer's room. I love an organizational technique. But he said that for the most part, the only thing you write down on those cards are just the main beats of the story. And you can move them around, you know,
索引卡上列出这个故事，我们之前也聊过这个。你很喜欢编剧室墙上的索引卡。我喜欢有条理的技术。但他说，大部分情况下，你在这些卡片上写的东西只有故事的主要情节节点。你可以随心所欲地移动它们，你知道的，
and then you figure out the flow, and then you make an outline, and you use that outline to make your first draft of the script. But with KoiPond, we're not sure that so much of what they were telling was a subtextual story between Michael and Jim, that Greg had them do something different when they were writing this episode. He said that they had to write the main story beats on white note cards and then they wrote all of the subtext on pink note cards. So anything that Michael and Jim were feeling went on pink and like plot went on white and he said it was really
然后你理清故事的脉络，接着写出大纲，并利用大纲写出剧本的第一稿。但在创作《锦鲤池》时——我们不确定他们讲述的有多少是迈克尔和吉姆之间的潜台词故事——格雷格（Greg）让他们在写这一集时采取了不同的做法。他说，他们必须把主要的故事节点写在白色的便签卡上，然后把所有的潜台词都写在粉红色的便签卡上。所以迈克尔和吉姆感受到的任何东西都写在粉色卡片上，而像情节这样的东西则写在白色卡片上。他说这真的
helpful for this episode and he gave some examples. So he said early on, Michael has a talking head where he wants to insult Jim and he starts off by saying that if Jim wants to be the boss, then he'll have to wear Michael's suit, which would be too small for him. But then Michael stops and he admits that Jim would probably still look good in it. Yeah, it's so great. He's like, damn it, he'd still look good. So the text is that he's mad at Jim, but the subtext is that he's still Envious of him.
对这一集非常有帮助，他还举了一些例子。他说在早期，迈克尔有一个对着镜头的独白（talking head），他想侮辱吉姆，他一开始说，如果吉姆想当老板，那他就得穿迈克尔的西装，但这套西装对吉姆来说太小了。但接着迈克尔停顿了一下，并承认吉姆穿这身可能依然会很好看。是的，太棒了。他当时就像是在说，该死，他穿起来还是很好看。所以明面上的台词是他在生吉姆的气，但潜台词是他依然
So Envious went on the pink card. And then of course, at the very end of the episode, Michael gets to have this talking headwary realizes that, wait, Jim is actually jealous of him. And so I just thought that was really, really interesting. The idea of mapping out the subtext. I love that. I mean, that's something we would do in our script's actors, like our
嫉妒吉姆。所以“嫉妒”这张卡片是粉红色的。然后当然，在这一集的结尾，迈克尔有了一段独白，他意识到，等等，其实吉姆是在嫉妒他。所以我当时觉得这真的非常非常有趣。规划潜台词这个主意。我太喜欢了。我是说，这正是我们作为演员在剧本中会做的事情，就像我们的
actory homework. We would get a script with like a paragraph that's like, Angela is mean to Oscar, right? And there's a speech where she's mean to Oscar, but the subtext is, Philip was turned away from daycare, right? So she's coming in with like shame and embarrassment. So in her angry speech to Oscar about him using her stapler, the subtext is, Angela's embarrassed, right? Yeah.
演员家庭作业一样。我们会拿到一个剧本，里面有一段话写着“安吉拉对奥斯卡很刻薄”，对吧？这里有一段她对奥斯卡刻薄的台词，但潜台词是“菲利普被日托中心拒绝了”，对吧？所以她带着羞耻和尴尬的情绪出场。因此，在她对奥斯卡使用她订书机一事发火的台词中，潜台词是：安吉拉感到很尴尬，对吧？是的。
So we would do that kind of thing, but I love that they did that in the writer's room too. It's like a really cool creative writing exercise. Yeah. Well, Angela, this brings us to fast-fact number three. Oh, I'm so excited for fast-fact number three. This is not Angela's digital clutter this week, folks. Sorry to disappoint. Guys, the plot of Michael falling into a co-pond
所以我们会做这种事情，但我很喜欢他们在编剧室里也这么做。这就像是一个非常酷的创意写作练习。是的。好吧，安吉拉，这就带我们来到了第三条幕后快讯。哦，我对第三条幕后快讯期待已久了。各位，这周可不是安吉拉的数码杂物哦。抱歉让大家失望了。伙们，迈克尔在去开会的路上
while on his way to a meeting is based on a real life event. This happened to Warren, you guys, the writer of this episode. Warren and Halstead together went on a meeting and Warren fell into a pond in a lobby. And here they are today to share the whole story with us. Yes, they each sent in audio clips and they were so fun, we decided to turn them into a fully sound-produced story thanks to our own Sam Kiefer. So here it is, the Inspiration of Coipon by Warren and Halstead. Hi, my name is Warren Lieberstein, and along with Halst Sullivan, we wrote the Koypond episode of The Office.
掉进锦鲤池的情节是基于真实生活事件改编的。这真的发生在沃伦身上，各位，这一集的编剧。沃伦和霍尔斯特德一起去开会，结果沃伦掉进了大厅的一个水池里。今天他们就在这里，跟我们分享整个故事。是的，他们各自发来了音频剪辑，内容太有趣了，以至于我们在自己的山姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer）的帮助下，决定把它们制作成一个完全带音效的故事。所以，这就是由沃伦和霍尔斯特德带来的《锦鲤池的灵感》。嗨，我叫沃伦·利伯斯坦，我和霍尔斯特德·沙利文一起编剧了《办公室》的《锦鲤池》那一集。
The idea for the story stemmed from my falling into a Koypond. What had happened was our agents set up a meeting for Halsted and I on the west side of Los Angeles. It was in this nice two-story office building. There was a marble reception, an open atrium lobby. There were these dark tavernteen floors. So we enter into this building for the meeting and I'm chewing gum. And I can't go to a meeting chewing gum, that's horribly unprofessional. And so I'm immediately looking for a trash can. More than I walk in for this meeting and you know I head over to the receptionist just to announce her names and and once says, oh I'm gonna go throw away my gum. or when I walk in for this meeting and you know I head over to the reception is
故事的灵感源于我掉进了一个锦鲤池。当时的情况是，我们的经纪人为我和霍尔斯特德在洛杉矶西区安排了一场会议。那是在一栋漂亮的双层办公楼里。里面有一个大理石前台、一个开放式中庭大厅。地面铺着深色的石灰华（travertine）地板。于是我们走进这栋大楼去开会，我当时正在嚼口香糖。我去开会总不能嚼着口香糖吧，那未免也太不专业了。所以我立刻开始寻找垃圾桶。当我走进大楼去开会时，你知道的，我朝前台走去，只是为了通报我们的名字，然后我说，哦，我去扔个口香糖。……或者说当我走进大楼去开会时，你知道的，我朝前台走去，
just to announce her names and and once says oh I'm gonna go throw away my gun. I see a trash can by the staircase off the corner so I walk over. After I toss my gum in the trash I turn and pivot on my right foot. My right foot somehow though doesn't reach the floor. So while I'm there at the desk, you know, checking in, suddenly I hear this huge splash. So my right foot doesn't find the floor and I lose my balance and I'm falling backwards. This point, real concerns that I'm falling to my death, down in open stairwell or whatever. concerns that I'm falling to my death, down an open stairwell or whatever. My legs did it first and I have no idea what size tank of water I'm falling into. But in this millisecond, I now believe I'm falling into a shark tank and I'm definitely
只是为了通报我们的名字，然后我说，哦，我去扔个口香糖。我看到角落楼梯旁有个垃圾桶，于是我走了过去。当我把口香糖扔进垃圾桶后，我转身，用右脚转了个轴。然而不知为何，我的右脚并没有踩到地面。所以当我站在前台那儿，你知道的，正在登记时，突然我听到“噗通”一声巨响。我的右脚没有踩到地面，我失去了平衡，开始向后倒去。就在这时，我真的担心自己会摔死，从开放式楼梯井或其他什么地方摔下去。我感到担心，自己会摔死，从开放式楼梯井或其他什么地方摔下去。我的双腿先着地，我完全不知道我掉进的是一个多大容量的水箱。但在这一毫秒内，我当时坚信自己是掉进了一个鲨鱼池，而且我绝对
going to die by shark attack. But after a second or so, I realize obviously I'm going to coi pond. I just nest deep plunged into it. I am drenched. And all I can say over and over again is, oh my god, oh, oh, oh, oh, my god, oh my god, oh my god. Holsted turns around and sees me. Warren is basically like lying in the pond splash and going, Oh my God, oh my God, oh my God. I'm like Warren, Warren, Warren, as Warren's sitting there splashing in the pond,
会被鲨鱼袭击致死。但过了一秒左右，我显然意识到，我掉进的是一个锦鲤池。我直接整个人深深地扎了进去。我湿透了。我嘴里能一遍又一遍说的只有：天哪，哦，哦，哦，哦，天哪，天哪，天哪。霍尔斯特德转过身来看到我。沃伦基本上就像是躺在水池的水花里，嘴里喊着：“天哪，天哪，天哪。”我当时就喊：沃伦，沃伦，沃伦，而沃伦就坐在水池里扑腾着水，
we look up, of course, everyone comes out of their offices to see what the commotion is. So basically everyone in this building is now staring. And on the railing, they're like eight people looking over, you know, on the first floor, all these people have come out to see all the commotion. My favorite part of Warren's description is the Nesti plunge into the Kui Pond, and also just like how disorienting that is.
我们抬头一看，当然，所有人都从各自的办公室里出来，想看看发生了什么骚动。所以基本上这栋楼里的所有人都盯着这边看。栏杆上有大约八个人探出头来看着，你知道的，在一楼，所有这些人都出来看看到底是怎么回事。我最喜欢沃伦对那次“深深扎入锦鲤池”的描述，还有那种不知所措的感觉。
Yeah, like it's gonna take you a minute. It's so many things, it's like I'm falling, I'm wet, why am I wet? Where am I? So I'm drenched, and there's so much water on this nice lobby floor. And someone comes up to us with a roll of those brown paper towels that you get from the bathroom. You know, they're just basically made of manila paper and have zero absorbency. And it's like, okay, thanks.
对啊，就像是你会需要花上一分钟缓过神来。这有太多状况了，感觉就像是我在下坠，我很湿，我为什么这么湿？我在哪儿？所以我就湿透了，这个漂亮的大厅地板上到处都是水。有人拿着一卷我们在洗手间能见到的那种棕色纸巾朝我们走来。你知道的，它们基本上就是马尼拉纸做的，吸水性为零。然后对方说，好吧，谢谢。
At this point, they leave, right? Because Warren is soaking wet. That's what you would think, Jenna. But you have to remember, we all live in Los Angeles and they had driven really far for this meeting. They actually offer us to move the meeting for a week later. But I'll stay wanted to keep the meeting because, you know, for those who don't live in LA, going to the West Side, no one wants to cross the 405 ever. The 405 is
到了这个时候，他们应该离开了吧，对吧？因为沃伦全身湿透了。你本来会这么想的，珍娜。但你得记住，我们都住在洛杉矶，而且他们为了这场会议开了很远的远程车。他们其实主动提出把会议推迟一周再开。但我坚持要按原计划开会，因为，你知道的，对于不住在洛杉矶的人来说，去西区，没人想过405高速公路。405是一条
highway and no matter what side of it you're on, traveling to the other is like a traffic nightmare. We know that around the corner is a sporting goods store. So we go there, you know, we walk in, warns soaking wet. I'm sopping wet. There was these two women working there, and I looked insane, like Jim Carrey, in Ace Ventura when he comes out of the bathroom.
高速公路，无论你在它的哪一侧，去到另一侧就像是一场交通噩梦。我们知道拐角处就有一家体育用品店。于是我们去了那里，你知道的，我们走进去时，沃伦湿透了。我全身湿漉漉的。那里有两个女员工在上班，而我看起来疯狂极了，就像《神探旺斯·佩查》（Ace Ventura）里的金·凯瑞从洗手间出来时那样。
Water's pouring all over the floor, and I just say, I need one of everything. We go back to the meeting, and Hallstad looks great, per usual. This is normal meeting outfit. And I look like a rap star from the 80s. It was a sports clothing store, so I could get really was a track suit. But we take the meeting, and of course all we can really talk about is me falling into
水顺着地板哗哗流淌，我直接说：“每样东西我都要一件。”我们回到会议室，霍尔斯特德看起来一如既往地帅气。这是他的标准开会行头。而我看起来像个80年代的说唱歌手。那是一家运动服装店，所以我能买到的其实是一套运动服。但我们还是开了会，当然，我们能聊的基本上全是我掉进
the goipun. And the puns were flying. They kept asking if I needed more water to, you know, all of it. And we used all that in the script. And then after the meeting, my agent called and said, I heard you made a splash at the meeting, which is a line that Aaron says in the show.
锦鲤池的事。双关语满天飞。他们一直问我需不需要更多水来……你知道的，各种调侃。我们在剧本里用上了所有这些。然后在会议结束后，我的经纪人打电话来说：“我听说你在会上溅起了巨大的水花（made a splash）。”这也是艾琳在剧中说的一句台词。
So that is the quipun story. Life imitates our, our, it rotates life. And you make an office episode out of it. [♪ music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in fell in the koi pond because I'm so glad it got turned into an episode that I thoroughly enjoyed. And you know what? This is what artists do. They take moments from their life and they turn it into art. Thank you Warren. Absolutely. I remember when it happened, you know, Warren is my ex-husband and we're still very good friends. And I remember saying, you know what? This will be a great story someday. And it was and it still is. Yes. Well on that note, I think we should take a break and then we'll come back and we'll get into this episode.
这就是锦鲤池的故事。生活模仿我们的……我们的，它让生活不断循环。然后你把这拍成了一集《办公室》。[♪ 背景音乐播放中 ♪] ……掉进了锦鲤池，因为我很高兴它能被拍成一集我非常喜欢的剧集。你知道吗？这就是艺术家做的事。他们把生活中的点滴转化为艺术。谢谢你，沃伦。当然。我记得当时事情发生的时候，你知道的，沃伦是我的前夫，我们现在仍然是非常要好的朋友。我记得当时还说：“你知道吗？这以后一定会是个好故事。”果不其然，现在依然是。好的，借此机会，我想我们应该休息一下，然后回来继续聊这一集。
Sounds great. Let's get started this week with a fan question, Angela. Great. This comes from Tom W. in San Francisco, California, who says, whenever this episode airs on Direct TV cable, the on-screen guide summarizes it as, quote, the office plans a haunted house for children in the community. But there's no mention of a haunted house in the episode
听起来真不错。这周我们先从一个粉丝提问开始吧，安吉拉。太好了。这个问题来自加利福尼亚州旧金山的汤姆·W（Tom W.），他说：每当这一集在 DirecTV 有线电视上播出时，屏幕上的节目指南将其概括为：“办公室为社区的孩子们策划了一场鬼屋活动。”但在这一集中
or deleted scenes or in any other episode that I can remember. Was this a storyline that the writers chose not to pursue? Well, Tom, here is your answer. This episode originally had a Halloween cold open. We shot it, and it actually aired because this episode came out the week of Halloween. And there is a haunted house in the warehouse,
或删除片段中，或者在我能记住的任何其他剧集中，都没有提到过鬼屋。这是编剧们选择放弃的剧情线吗？好吧，汤姆，这就是你的答案。这一集原本有一个万圣节的开场白（cold open）。我们拍了，而且它确实播出了，因为这一集播出的那周正好是万圣节。仓库里确实有一个鬼屋，
and Michael fake hangs himself in the haunted house. And after it aired, NBC decided to pull it from all future episodes. So that's why you're seeing it in your description, but the cold open is not there anymore. It's also not on the DVDs in the deleted scene section. There are photos of the cast and their costumes from this episode online. I was a spider. Mindy was Lilloo from Fifth Element. Yeah, I think this is the one where Jim is Facebook, but he just wrote book on his face for Facebook. That's right. But anyway guys, instead this episode opens in Jim's office.
而且迈克尔在鬼屋里假装上吊。节目播出后，NBC决定将其从所有未来的重播中撤下。所以这就是为什么你会在节目简介里看到它，但开场白已经不在了。它也没有收录在DVD的删除片段部分里。网上有一些这一集中演员身穿万圣节服装的照片。我扮的是蜘蛛。敏迪扮的是《第五元素》里的莉露。是的，我想这一集里吉姆扮的是 Facebook（脸书），但他只是把“书”（book）字写在了脸上当作 Facebook。没错。不过话说回来，伙们，这一集的开头是吉姆的办公室。
And Michael is sharing about his plans for the weekend. Yeah, he's gonna go to a garlic festival. It's a real thing, lady. Is it? There is a Pocano, Garlic, and Harvest festival. I looked it up. It is held every year on Labor Day weekend in the Shawnee Mountain Ski area.
迈克尔正在分享他周末的计划。是的，他要去参加一个大蒜节。这是真事，女士。是吗？波科诺（Pocono）确实有一个大蒜丰收节。我查过了。它每年在劳动节周末在肖尼山滑雪度假村（Shawnee Mountain Ski area）举办。
The festival is Saturday and Sunday. Angela, I think we have to go. I was just, I was about to say it. I know I say that every time you bring up one of these things, but I am telling you, I would love a garlic festival. I bet they have all kinds of things made from garlic. Lady, listen to what your ticket price includes.
这个节日持续周六和周日两天。安吉拉，我觉得我们必须去。我正要……我正准备说呢。我知道每次你提起这类事情我都会这么说，但我告诉你，我太想去大蒜节了。我敢打赌他们有各种用大蒜做成的东西。女士，听听你的门票价格都包含了什么。
I can't wait. Four stages of continuous live music. Great. Professional chef cooking demonstrations. Ding ding ding. Farmer garlic growing seminars as well as children's craft activities. Can adults do the craft activities? I was gonna say you got to have a craft table at a festival. I found out that Pennsylvania is home to something called hardneck garlic. Hardneck garlic, it's a type of garlic.
我等不及了。四个连续现场音乐舞台。太棒了。专业大厨烹饪演示。叮叮叮。农夫大蒜种植研讨会以及儿童手工活动。成年人可以参加手工活动吗？我正想说，你去这种节日总得有个手工桌吧。我发现宾夕法尼亚州有一种叫做硬颈大蒜（hardneck garlic）的东西。硬颈大蒜，这是一种大蒜。
And there are three main types of hardneck garlic. They are rock and bowl-lay. If I'm pronouncing that correctly. It has a rich, full-bodied taste, and it'll last up to six months. There's porcelain, hard-knit garlic. That'll stay good up to eight months, and then there's purple stripe hard-knit garlic. And it's famous for making the best baked garlic. It has a distinctive bright purple streak on that papery sheath. I've seen that. Well, if you need to bake your garlic,
硬颈大蒜主要有三种类型。它们是罗克姆博尔（Rocambole），如果我发音准确的话。它具有浓郁醇厚的口感，可以保存长达六个月。还有瓷白硬颈大蒜（porcelain hard-neck garlic）。这种可以保存长达八个月，然后还有紫条硬颈大蒜（purple stripe hard-neck garlic）。它以制作出最棒的烤大蒜而闻名。它的纸质外皮上有独特的亮紫色条纹。我见过这个。好吧，如果你需要烤大蒜，
you're gonna wanna buy that purple stripe garlic. Okay. Anyway, Michael's going to the garlic festival. He's also very excited because there is a TCBY booth. I remember us all going to get yogurt. There was this like yogurt phase. I think it's still happening, obviously, right? There's lots of yogurt places.
你就会想要买那种紫条大蒜。好吧。不管怎样，迈克尔要去大蒜节。他还非常兴奋，因为那里有一个 TCBY 酸奶摊位。我记得我们所有人都去买过酸奶。当时有一股酸奶热潮。我想现在这股热潮还在继续，对吧？有很多酸奶店。
But I feel like TCBY was the first one where we were all like, oh my gosh, let's go get yogurt. No, Steve used to come to work. Very excited when he found a new frozen yogurt place. He was especially into it. I feel like this line maybe came from that real life obsession. It was a thing.
但我觉得TCBY是第一家让我们所有人都忍不住喊“哦天哪，去买酸奶吧”的店。不，史蒂夫以前来上班时。当他发现一家新的冷冻酸奶店时会超级兴奋。他对此格外热衷。我觉得这句台词可能就源于他现实生活中的这种痴迷。这确实是一股潮流。
It did crack me up that Michael says, yeah, it stands for I Can't Believe It's Yogurt. Yes. But it's TCBY. I looked it up, Jenna. And it actually stands for the country's best yogurt. TCBY, the country's best yogurt. Oh, there used to be one in Scranton,
让我觉得搞笑的是，迈克尔说：“对，它代表‘我简直不敢相信这是酸奶’（I Can't Believe It's Yogurt）。”是的。但其实是 TCBY。我查过了，珍娜。它实际上代表的是“这个国家最好的酸奶”（the country's best yogurt）。TCBY，这个国家最好的酸奶。哦，斯克兰顿以前曾有一家，
heard the internet and the fashion mall, but it's no longer there. Huh, there you go. Aaron is gonna interrupt all of this talk of garlic and TCBY to say that rapskin design called and is expecting both of them for their meeting in an hour. And Jim's like hold up, it's just me. Michael is delighted that they want him to tag along.
我听说是在服装商场里，但现在已经没有了。哈，原来如此。艾琳打断了所有关于大蒜和 TCBY 的讨论，说拉普斯金设计公司（Rapskin Design）打电话来，期待他们一小时后去开会。吉姆说，等等，只有我一个人。迈克尔听到他们想让他也跟着去，高兴坏了。
Yeah. I know. He's like, really? Oh! They want me as well. Oh, wow. He's all like playing like he's not delighted. That must have been a pink card.
是的。我知道。他当时就像是，真的吗？哦！他们也想要我去？哦，哇。他表现得好像他一点也不高兴似的。那张卡片肯定是一张粉色卡片。
Pink card, Michael's delighted. Yes. Well, Michael's gonna try to prep Jim for this meeting. Oh my gosh, Jenna, in deleted scenes, this was a much bigger moment. It cracked me up. Michael's like, this office is very formal, Jim. You don't just say, Dave, it's Mr. Bourd chart,
粉色卡片：迈克尔很高兴。是的。好吧，迈克尔打算为这场会议给吉姆做做准备。哦天哪，珍娜，在删除片段中，这是一个大得多的时刻。把我逗乐了。迈克尔说：“这个办公室非常正式，吉姆。你不能随口就说‘戴夫，我是伯特查先生’，
and also, is that what you're wearing? And then the scene would have continued, where Michael is gonna help Jim. Retie his tie. He says he needs a double dimple. A double dimple, have you ever heard of this, Jenna? No, can we hear it? Is that what you are wearing?
还有，你穿的是什么呀？”然后场景会继续，迈克尔要帮吉姆。重新系领带。他说他需要一个“双酒窝结”（double dimple）。双酒窝结，你听说过这个吗，珍娜？没有，能让我们听听吗？那是你穿的衣服吗？
Yes, it is. How about the knot on the tie, double dimple? I think we need to go. No, don't touch my teeth. need to double dimple. Your tie, Jim. Come on. Here we go. I want you to look good. I can't turn around. No. Come on. I can only do this in one direction. And here we go. Here we go. I don't want them to think that you are a country pumpkin. And then up through the rabbit hole around the merry-go-round and up again through the rabbit hole and down into the go-for-hole up, up, up. How do we look? That's perfect.
是的，它是。领带上的结怎么样，双酒窝结？我想我们该走了。不，别碰我的牙齿。需要系双酒窝结。你的领带，吉姆。来吧。我们开始吧。我希望你看起来精神点。我没法转身。不。来吧。我只能朝一个方向做这个。开始啦。开始啦。我可不想让他们觉得你是个乡巴佬。然后穿过兔子洞，绕过旋转木马，再穿过兔子洞向上，钻进地鼠洞向下，上，上，上。我们看起来怎么样？太完美了。
Okay, so in the scene Michael steps behind him and Jim is so annoyed. He unties this tie that was really well tied. He does this rabbit hole, go for a hole. He's very awkwardly trying to reach over Jim, who's taller than he is, right? And then when he spins him around and says, how do we look? He just looks, the tie looks horrible. Is there a double dimple now? I couldn't see a double dimple.
好吧，在这个场景中，迈克尔走到他身后，吉姆感到非常恼火。他解开了这条原本系得很好的领带。他做着兔子洞、地鼠洞的手势。他非常笨拙地试图够到比他个子高的吉姆，对吧？然后当他把吉姆转过身来说“我们看起来怎么样？”时，吉姆一看，那领带看起来简直糟透了。现在有双酒窝结了吗？我看不出有什么双酒窝结。
And Jim's collar is all messed up. And it's just a really physically funny scene. But it got me curious, what is a double dimple? Jenna, this is all over the internet. It's clearly important when it comes to tying a tie. What? Yeah, there's video tutorials. One says, the perfect dimple every time.
而且吉姆的领口全弄乱了。这绝对是一个肢体动作上非常搞笑的场景。但这也让我很好奇，到底什么是双酒窝结？珍娜，网上到处都是这个。在系领带这事上，它显然很重要。什么？是的，有视频教程。其中一个说：每次都能系出完美的酒窝结。
There was a quote I found online that said, dimples matter. You'll see this even in the simplest of tie knots. The fore in hand, make sure you create the dimple under the knot, otherwise your tie will look flatter and less finished. Wow! No one wants a flat tie.
我在网上看到过一句名言，上面写着：“酒窝至关重要。即使在最简单的领带结中，你也会看到这一点。四手结（four-in-hand），确保你在结下方营造出酒窝，否则你的领带看起来会更扁平、更缺乏精致感。”哇！没人想要一条扁平的领带。
You need the double dimple. I had no idea. But it was a really cute scene where Michael is basically trying to get Jim all spiffy. Well, Michael also wants him to change his watch. He says, you need a tanker'd watch. I looked that up. That's not a watch. There's no such thing.
你需要双酒窝结。我以前完全不知道。不过这是一个非常可爱的场景，迈克尔基本上是在试图让吉姆看起来精神抖擞。好吧，迈克尔还想让他换块手表。他说：“你需要一块坦克表（tank'd watch）。”我查过了。根本没有这种表。根本没有这回事。
There's no such thing as a tanker'd watch. There is such thing as a tank watch. It's a Cartier watch. Apparently it was designed after the tanks of the World War II battlefields. It has a rectangular face. So when Michael is handing Jim this rectangular face watch, he's, I don't know.
根本没有什么“坦克德表”（tankard watch）。不过确实有“坦克表”（tank watch）。那是卡地亚（Cartier）的手表。显然它的设计灵感来自第二次世界大战战场上的坦克。它有一个矩形表盘。所以当迈克尔把这款矩形表盘的手表递给吉姆时，我不知道……
I feel like maybe someone kind of like with his fake say-ko. Maybe they sold him a fake tank watch and called it a tankard. A tankard is actually a drinking stone. It's sort of like a beerstein. That's what a tankard is. I learned, oh my gosh. Isn't that crazy? That is crazy. A tank watch by Cartier sells for like $4,000. Yalza. So that's clearly what Michael thinks he has purchased. He's purchased a tanker. A tanker. We're about to start a really fun runner between Pam and Andy. Jenna, this must have been a blast. You had Ed Helms to yourself doing all these bits all day. I loved this runner.
我觉得可能有人就像卖给他假精工（seiko）手表一样。可能有人卖给他一块假坦克表，还管它叫“坦克德表”（tankard）。而“坦克德”（tankard）实际上是一个带把的饮水杯。有点像啤酒大杯。那才叫坦克德。我学到了，天哪。是不是很疯狂？太疯狂了。卡地亚的坦克表售价大概要4000美元。哇噢。所以这显然是迈克尔自认为买到的东西。他买了个“坦克德”。一个坦克德。我们即将开始潘和安迪之间一个非常有趣的连贯小笑料。珍娜，这一定太爽了。你独自和埃德·赫尔姆斯（Ed Helms）合作，一整天都在搞这些小包袱。我太喜欢这个连贯小笑料了。
It was so much fun. We had the best time. You know that scene where Andy is singing the directory? I wrote it out. I wrote the whole thing out. I'm going to go on drilling. Where are you? Dean Trophy, Sweet 100, and Doodley Do. is singing the directory. I wrote it out. I wrote the whole thing out. How about Hondriiling? Where are you? Dean Trophy, Sweet 100, and Doodly Do.
太有趣了。我们度过了最棒的时光。你知道安迪在唱电话黄页的那场戏吗？我把它写下来了。我把整段都写下来了。我要继续钻探。你在哪？Dean Trophy、Sweet 100 还有 Doodley Do。在唱电话黄页。我把它写下来了。我把整段都写下来了。那 Hondriiling 呢？你在哪？Dean Trophy、Sweet 100 还有 Doodly Do。
Sherman Blinds and Rug, Sweet 202, Palabond Rilling. I mean, I was cracking up. Yeah, Ed made that up. I mean, he made up that tune. He made up the whole melody. He did. That was just on the fly. And we knew that I was going to cut him off at the end with the whole melody. He did. That was just on the fly. And we knew that I was gonna cut him off at the end
Sherman Blinds and Rug，Sweet 202，Palabond Rilling。我是说，我当时笑疯了。对，那是埃德即兴创作的。我是说，那段曲调是他编的。整段旋律都是他编的。是的。那完全是当场发挥。而且我们知道我最后会用整段旋律打断他。是的。那完全是当场发挥。而且我们知道我最后会用整段旋律打断他
with the sweet 401. Yeah, and then he couldn't resolve the melody and his brain hurt. Yeah, he said it felt like he was holding in a sneeze. Well, Warren shared they loved your look to camera when Andy sings sweet faux. Like as the door shut. And I have to tell you guys, you know, I've known Warren and Hallstead a very long time.
带上 Sweet 401。对，然后他接不上那个旋律，脑子都快炸了。对，他说感觉像憋着一个喷嚏打不出来。对了，沃伦分享说，他们很喜欢安迪唱 Sweet faux 时你看着镜头的眼神。就像门关上的时候。我必须告诉大家，你们知道的，我和沃伦还有霍尔斯特德认识很久了。
And they were both in Acapella and college. So I have to imagine this scene was just such a fun moment for them. I've got a location alert for my scenes with Ed. We did shoot one entire day out in Woodland Hills, California at the Warner Center corporate park. We did everything in this one office. So basically, they dressed two different offices, one to be palpobond drilling and then later read diamond labs when we're going to meet with Miss Gifford. And we also did the driving scenes on that same day. So this was truly a full day, just me and Ed
他们俩在大学时都唱过无伴奏合唱。所以我猜，这场戏对他们来说一定是个非常有趣的时刻。我有一个关于我和埃德对手戏的外景提醒。我们确实在加州伍德兰希尔斯的华纳中心公司园区外拍了一整天。所有的戏份都在这间办公室里拍完的。所以基本上，他们布置了两个不同的办公室，一个作为 Palabond 钻探公司，后来又改成红钻实验室，那是我们要去见吉福德女士的地方。我们还在同一天拍了开车的戏。所以这真的是满满的一天，只有我和埃德
and Reggie and Warren and Hallstead basically. It was awesome. Back at the office, Michael and Jim returned from their meeting and Michael is soaked. I mean, he is drenched. Well, he was caught in a flash flood storm is what happened. Yeah.
还有雷吉、沃伦和霍尔斯特德。太棒了。回到办公室，迈克尔和吉姆开完会回来了，迈克尔浑身湿透。我是说，他湿透了。好吧，事情是这样的，他遇上了一场山洪暴风雨。对。
Jim out ran it, though. That's why he's dry. Yeah, ran the storm. Meredith was like, no way. If there was rain, my hip would have been throbbing. I know. So, I want you to note something in this scene at three minutes thirty-five seconds. I have a background catch. Did you see Angela Martens sassy
不过吉姆跑得比雨快。所以他才没湿。对，跑赢了风暴。梅雷迪思当时说，怎么可能。如果有雨，我的胯骨早就开始剧痛了。我懂。所以，我想让你们注意这场戏在三分三十五秒的一个细节。我有一个背景彩蛋。你看到安吉拉·马丁那风情万种的
wavy pony tail? No. A wavy pony. Yeah, I clocked it right away because wavy ponytail means one thing. It means we had been to a fancy party, and this is day two hair for me. I showed up at work with great hair that had been blown out and styled the night before, and that's when Kim Ferry, who did my hair, would usually put it in a cute pony. Oh! And then we would have to match the wave every day that I worked after that. Sassy Ponytail led me to my digital clutter, and lady, we filmed this episode in September of 2009 around the time of the Emmys.
波浪马尾辫了吗？没有。波浪马尾。对，我一眼就注意到了，因为波浪马尾意味着一件事。这意味着我们去参加过一个盛大的派对，这是我头发的第二天造型。我上班时带着吹风定型后的绝佳发型，那是前一晚弄的，通常这时候，负责我发型的金·费里就会把它扎成一个可爱的马尾。哦！然后从那以后，我每天上班都得复刻那个波浪卷。风情马尾辫让我想起了我的数码杂物，各位，我们是在 2009 年 9 月艾美奖前后拍摄这一集的。
Oh! And I also wrote that my parents were in town for the Emmys. This is the year my dad went with me. Yeah. So I took them to everything I could get us invited to because I really wanted them to fill the whole experience of like going to the Emmys and the parties. So yeah, I had sassy ponytail left over hair. Well, that is amazing.
哦！我还写道，我父母当时为了艾美奖来到了镇上。正是我爸爸跟我一起去的这一年。对。所以我带他们去了一切能弄到邀请函的地方，因为我真的很想让他们体验一下去艾美奖和派对的全过程。所以，是的，我留着风情马尾辫的隔夜发型。好吧，这太惊人了。
And Angela, look at that. Your digital clutter. It made it into this episode after all. I snuck in well done. Thank you. Well, I wanted to point something out in the background of this as well. This is at three minutes, 13 seconds. The watercolor on the wall.
还有安吉拉，看这个。你的数码杂物。它最终还是出现在这一集里了。我悄悄塞进去的，干得漂亮。谢谢。对了，我也想指出这一集背景里的一个细节。时间是三分十三秒。墙上的那幅水彩画。
It has been replaced with a photo of a golf course that says failure is not an option. Yeah, it's been replaced with an inspirational poster. Mm-hmm. Although nothing's more inspiring than Pam's watercolor. It's hope in a frame, Jenna. It is. I know.
它被换成了一张写着“失败不是选项”的高尔夫球场照片。对，它被换成了一张励志海报。嗯哼。虽然没有什么比潘的水彩画更励志了。那是框起来的希望，珍娜。确实是。我懂。
It's going to be back. It'll come back. Don't worry. It's coming back. Pam and Andy are now chatting with the receptionist. I watched the scene. I rewound it because I laughed so hard. I feel like this is something I say when I'm in my mom mode.
它会回来的。它会回来的。别担心。它会回来的。潘和安迪现在正跟前台聊天。我看过这场戏。我倒回去看了好几遍，因为笑得太厉害了。我觉得这就像是我进入“妈妈模式”时会说的话。
Looks like someone's got a case of the definitely. Hahaha. Oh my gosh, Pam is so mortified when the reception thinks she's a couple with Andy and she does that thing where she overcompensates, where she's like, no, no, no, no, definitely not definitely not no, no, no, no. Yeah, she keeps repeating it. The receptionist was played by
看来有人得了“绝对症”了。哈哈哈哈。哦天哪，当前台觉得她和安迪是一对时，潘尴尬得要命，她开始做出那种反应过度的事情，比如，不，不，不，不，绝对不是，绝对不是，不，不，不，不。对，她一直在重复。前台是由
Jennifer Hastie. She's been in tons of stuff. She's been on Bosch, Better Call Saul, transparent and true blood. And Angela, we had the hardest time getting through the scene. It was it was really difficult because they wanted me to really go on too long. Like way too long before Andy says somebody has a case of the definitely's. The direction was like keep hearing this idea in your head. Like re-realize it over and over again. So I think I do it like three times where I'm like no definitely not. Oh no no no definitely not. Oh, no, no, no, definitely not. No, no, no, no, no, no. It's as if she keeps saying it, but she's not saying it.
珍妮弗·哈斯蒂饰演的。她演过超级多作品。她演过《博斯》、《风骚律师》、《透明家庭》和《真爱如血》。安吉拉，我们拍这场戏时简直难得要命。真的非常困难，因为他们希望我真的演得太久了。就像在安迪说有人得了“绝对症”之前，铺垫得超级久。导演的要求就像是让这个想法一直回响在你的脑海里。就像是一遍又一遍地重新意识到它。所以我想我大概演了三次，我说不，绝对不是。哦不，不，不，绝对不是。哦，不，不，不，绝对不是。不，不，不，不，不，不。就好像她一直在说，但其实她没在说。
That was the direction was to keep hearing it and responding. Well, that was really funny. I loved it. Well, Warren and Holstead said that this plot was loosely based on a story that they heard in their real life, but they couldn't remember now who it was, but they said they had a female friend who was pregnant and she went to IKEA with a male friend,
导演的要求就是一直听到这个词并做出反应。好吧，这真的太搞笑了。我很喜欢。对了，沃伦和霍尔斯特德说，这个情节是根据他们现实生活中听到的一个故事改编的，但他们现在记不清是谁了，不过他们说有一个女性朋友怀孕了，她和一个男性朋友一起去宜家，
not her husband, and everyone kept referring to them as a couple. And they were just like, we get it. I mean, we're shopping for furniture together and I'm pregnant, everyone just kept congratulating them. And so they remembered that and that's kind of the inspiration for this plotline. And I'm sure in that moment at first you're like, oh, actually we're not related. Oh, actually we're not a couple. Oh yeah, yeah. And then at some point you're like, yeah, sure. We just, because it's just easier to go with it. You're like, you need to buy
不是她丈夫，然后每个人都以为他们是一对。他们当时就想，我们懂的。我是说，我们一起挑家具，而且我怀孕了，每个人都一直在祝贺他们。所以他们记住了这件事，这基本上就是这个情节的灵感来源。我敢肯定，在那个瞬间，一开始你会觉得，哦，其实我们没有关系。哦，其实我们不是一对。哦，对，对。然后到某个时候你会想，对，没错。我们只是——因为顺着他们的话说更省事。你会觉得，你得买
what we're buying. Yes, sure. We're gonna get out of there. Back at the office, Eric gets an interesting phone call. She does. It's from the custodian at Raskin Design. Apparently, they found Michael's keys in the coin pond. Hmm. She announces this out loud. And the bull pin is an instant buzz,
我们正在买的东西。没错。当然。我们得赶紧离开那儿。回到办公室，埃琳接到了一个有趣的电话。确实如此。是拉斯金设计公司的管理员打来的。显然，他们在锦鲤池里找到了迈克尔的钥匙。嗯。她大声宣布了这件事。
coin pond, your keys in the KoiPon, everyone is very curious. I love the cut to the next moment where Michael's phone rings, and then we pull out and reveal everyone hovering around reception, and Aaron just being like, Michael, people have a lot of questions.
办公区瞬间炸开了锅，锦鲤池，你的钥匙在锦鲤池里，每个人都好奇极了。我喜欢接下来的镜头切换，迈克尔的电话响了，然后镜头拉远，露出每个人都围在前台周围，而埃琳则说，迈克尔，大家有很多问题要问。
These scenes were always so much fun to film because it's just a big group clump and we got to have like our dialogue sort of rapid fire back and forth. I have such fun memories of doing scenes like that. Well, the truth is gonna come out. Michael tries to say, yes, he fell in a koi pond,
拍这些戏总是那么有趣，因为这只是一大群人聚在一起，我们的台词就像机关枪一样快节奏地一来一回。拍这样的戏给我留下了非常美好的回忆。好吧，真相要大白了。迈克尔试图辩解，是的，他是掉进锦鲤池了，
but how do they know that he wasn't trying to save a child? And Angela's like, so a child fell in the coi pond. And Michael's like, not yet! Not yet! It's amazing. Jim has a great talking head. He says it wasn't so much how Michael fell in, but it was how long it took him to get out.
但他们怎么知道他不是在试图拯救一个孩子呢？安吉拉就说，所以是个孩子掉进锦鲤池了。迈克尔就说：还没呢！还没呢！太绝了。吉姆有一个很棒的采访镜头。他说与其说是迈克尔怎么掉进去的，不如说他花了多长时间才爬出来。
You know that's gotta be true. You know like getting out of that Koi Pond for Warren. I thought the same thing. Realizing what had happened and all the people looking over the railing at him. Oh my gosh. Well, it's time for Pam and Andy to do their big pitch, right? They've got their sales pitch.
你知道这绝对是真的。你知道，对沃伦来说，从那个锦鲤池里爬出来。我也是这么想的。意识到发生了什么，所有人都在栏杆上看着他。哦天哪。好吧，该轮到潘和安迪做他们的大力推销了，对吧？他们准备好销售说辞了。
Yes, they're talking to Tim Dockery and he's really impressed. He's especially impressed, you know, because he's running a family business and they're clearly a family business. Pam and Andy have to do the, oh no, we're not, we're actually not a couple. No, no.
对，他们正在跟蒂姆·多克里谈，他印象非常深刻。他特别印象深刻，你知道的，因为他在经营一家家族企业，而他们显然也是一家家族企业。潘和安迪不得不开始——哦不，我们不是，我们其实不是一对。不，不。
But then Andy goes on and on. Well, it's payback time. It's payback time for the lady who had a case of the definitely. I guess so. And he says, oh yeah, no, I'm not with her. I only date face models on a scale from one to Jezelle, like my girlfriend's a nine. Pam's just a surrogate, you know, because we don't need her to look good. I loved that. Apparently, like, we're not a couple, but that is his baby. Oh, yeah. He's going to claim the baby. Yeah.
但接着安迪开始滔滔不绝。好吧，报应来了。对于那个得了“绝对症”的女士来说，报应来了。我猜是的。然后他说，哦对，不，我没跟她在一起。我只跟颜值在吉赛尔级别的封面模特约会，比如我女朋友是个九分。潘只是个代孕的，你知道的，因为我们不需要她长得好看。我太喜欢这个了。显然，就好像我们不是一对，但那绝对是他的孩子。哦，是的。他要认领那个孩子。对。
All right. I have two things to point out in the scene. Number one is my guest star alert, Tom Yee played Tim Dockery. According to his bio, he has lived in four countries on three continents. Impressive. Yeah. And he has been on the West Wing arrest the development
好了。这场戏我有两点要指出。第一点是我的客串明星提醒，汤姆·伊饰演蒂姆·多克里。根据他的个人简介，他曾在三个大洲的四个国家生活过。令人印象深刻。对。而且他演过《白宫群风》、《发展受阻》
Dr. Ken, community and monk. Monk connection. We got another one of those. It's been a while. Yeah. And then at three minutes, 55 seconds, I wanted to point out Pam's baby bump. Okay. It is much more pronounced in this episode compared to last episode, and that is because I am wearing Bump B.
《肯医生》、《废柴联盟》和《神探阿蒙》。阿蒙连结。我们又找到一个。好久不见了。对。然后是在三分五十五秒，我想指出潘的婴儿孕肚。好的。相比上一集，这一集里她的肚子明显隆起得多，那是因为我戴着 B 号孕肚。
You've gone up a size in the bump. I've gone up a bump. Alicia, our costume designer, made a document that she called the belly tracker. And she tracked from the first time we heard of Pam's pregnancy news all the way to when she would give birth, and she painstakingly mapped out each time we needed to go up in a belly. And this was our first belly bump. We went up to bump B. They became increasingly less comfortable
你的孕肚码数升级了。我升了一个孕肚级别。艾莉西亚，我们的服装设计师，制作了一份她称之为“肚子追踪器”的文件。她记录了从我们第一次听到潘怀孕的消息一直到她生孩子的全过程，她煞费苦心地规划了我们每次需要更换更大号肚子的时间。这就是我们的第一个假肚子。我们换到了 B 号孕肚。它们变得越来越不舒服，
and I became increasingly more miserable. I have something to share about that later that you don't know, but I'm waiting. I'm waiting. Oh my gosh. Well, Angela, I look forward to whatever this piece of information is that you will be giving me later. Yeah, I think it's going to make you laugh.
而我也变得越来越痛苦。关于这个，我之后有个事要分享，你还不知道，但我先留着。我等着。哦天哪。好吧，安吉拉，我很期待你待会儿要告诉我的这个消息。对，我觉得这会让你笑出来的。
Okay. Before we leave this scene, Jenna, I wanted to share with you guys that the name Tim Dockery actually came from Warren's best friend from college, who's Martin Dockery. Hi, Martin. But I guess the name Martin didn't clear. Tim is Martin's brother. So there you go. Tim Dockery. And it was always fun when our writers got to put
好吧。在离开这场戏之前，珍娜，我想跟你们分享的是，蒂姆·多克里这个名字其实是取自沃伦大学时的死党，也就是马丁·多克里。嗨，马丁。但我猜“马丁”这个名字没通过审核。蒂姆是马丁的兄弟。所以就这样。蒂姆·多克里。每当我们的编剧有机会把
a friend's name or a relative's name in an episode. The next scene has a joke in it that made me laugh so hard. Am I a dork? Michael asks Aaron for one of those clips that hold paper together and Aaron says staples. Staples? Yeah. I loved it. I did too. Aaron tells Michael that David Wallace called to say that he heard Michael made a big splash at the meeting. But then she immediately backtracks because that didn't really happen and she feels bad and everybody put her up to it.
朋友或亲戚的名字写进剧集里时，总是非常有趣。下一场戏里有一个笑话让我笑得前仰后合。我是个呆子吗？迈克尔向埃琳索要那种把纸夹在一起的夹子，埃琳说是订书钉。订书钉？对。我太喜欢了。我也是。埃琳告诉迈克尔，大卫·华莱士打电话来说，他听说迈克尔在会议上引起了巨大轰动。但随后她立刻改口了，因为那其实并没有发生，而且她觉得很不好意思，是大家怂恿她这么做的。
She says Kevin and Meredith put me up to it, and then Kevin leans through the file cabinet and says, I will kill you. But yes, that line is inspired from the real life event. When Warren's agent called and said, I heard you made a big splash. We had a fan question from LAB in Ontario. At seven minutes, 13 seconds, you can see a picture of a fish tank on Pam's computer, which is Gymsold desk, and then a couple seconds later, you can see the same
她说凯文和梅雷迪思怂恿我的，然后凯文从文件柜后面探出头来说，我要杀了你。不过没错，这句台词的灵感来源于现实生活中的事件。当时沃伦的经纪人打电话来说，我听说你引起了巨大轰动。我们收到了来自安大略省 LAB 的粉丝提问。在七分十三秒时，你可以在潘的电脑上看到一张鱼缸的照片，那是吉姆以前的座位，然后几秒钟后，你可以在安迪的电脑上看到同样的
screen saver on Andy's computer. Was this a nod to the Koi pond? It was, and in fact, if you watch Michael walk through the bullpen, he clocks Andy's computer. And obviously, Pam and Andy don't know anything about the falling in the Koi pond. They are not at the office to change their screens. So I guess you have to imagine that someone in the office is doing this. Well, in the deleted scenes, it's clear that Kevin is having maybe the most fun with this.
屏保。这是在致敬锦鲤池吗？是的，事实上，如果你看迈克尔走过办公区，他注意到了安迪的电脑。很显然，潘和安迪对掉进锦鲤池一无所知。他们不在办公室里，没理由去换壁纸。所以我想你只能想象是办公室里的某个人干的。好吧，在删减片段中，很明显凯文对这件事觉得最好玩。
I don't know if it's Kevin, usually the one that falls or trips or something happens and now someone else has had a big fall. But in the deleted scenes as Michael walks through the bullpen, Kevin makes this noise with each step. Like water, like squishy water in your shoes and Michael's like stop it. So someone in the office was really having fun. Well Michael is going to hold a sensitivity training meeting in the conference room. Yeah. And we're going to make a list. We're going to make a list of things that we can no longer talk about. No teasing, it's called a do not mock list.
我不知道是不是凯文，通常是那个人摔倒或绊倒或者发生了什么事，现在别人也经历了一次大跌。但在删减片段中，当迈克尔走过办公区时，凯文每走一步都会发出这种声音。像水声，像鞋子里踩了水的黏糊糊的声音，然后迈克尔说：停下。所以办公室里的某个人真的玩得很开心。好吧，迈克尔要在会议室里召开一场敏感度培训会议。对。我们要列个清单。我们要列一份不能再谈论的事情清单。禁止取笑，这叫“免喷清单”。
Michael writes the first one, Koi Pond, and he also admits he's fallen into the fountain at the steam town mall as well, so he writes Koi Pond and Fountain. We had a fan catch from Victoria S in Orlando, Florida, when Michael says he's fallen into a fountain at the steam town mall, I don't think there's actually a fountain there. I was born and raised in northeast Pennsylvania. I have been to the steentown mall, and I don't recall seeing one there. Well, Victoria, our producer Cassie wanted to find out. Cassie, tell us what? What do you know about the fountain at Steentown mall? Do you have a deep dive, Cassie tell us what do you know about the fountain at Steve Tom mall?
迈克尔写下了第一条，锦鲤池，而且他也承认自己也掉进过蒸汽镇购物中心的喷泉里，所以他写下了锦鲤池和喷泉。我们收到了来自佛罗里达州奥兰多的维多利亚 S 的粉丝抓包，当迈克尔说他掉进蒸汽镇购物中心的喷泉时，我觉得那里实际上根本没有喷泉。我在宾夕法尼亚州东北部出生长大。我去过蒸汽镇购物中心，我不记得那里有什么喷泉。好吧，维多利亚，我们的制作人卡西想要查明真相。卡西，告诉我们什么？关于蒸汽镇购物中心的喷泉你知道些什么？你有做深度调查吗，卡西，告诉我们关于蒸汽镇购物中心的喷泉你知道些什么？
Do you have a deep dive Cassie? Yes, I have a little deep dive of me trying to figure out if there was some fountain at the steam town mall I Called an emailed and I could not get through and I think they probably were like super weirded out by me just saying like I just want to know if there's a fountain here were like super weirded out by me just saying like, hi, I just want to know if there's a fountain here. So they weren't responding to me. And I like went on Google, I tried to look at pictures, I watched like old news clips of people doing segments
你有做深度调查吗，卡西？是的，我做了一点小小的深度调查，试图弄清楚蒸汽镇购物中心是不是真的有什么喷泉。我打电话又发邮件，但根本打不进去，我觉得他们大概觉得我超级诡异，因为我一直在说“我只是想知道这里有没有喷泉”，他们觉得“超级诡异”，因为我一直说“嗨，我只是想知道这里有没有喷泉”。所以他们根本不理我。然后我上了谷歌，试图看照片，我还看了人们在
at the mall and I could not find a fountain. I was about to give up and I was like, you know what, I'm going to reach out to the office ladies Facebook fan page because people post like pictures of them in Scranton. So I reached out to Nikki who moderates it. And then she was like, I'm on it. And like a couple hours later, she got back to me and was like, so I couldn't find any pictures. I called the steam down mall, got a hold of someone. They were very weirded out by her asking
购物中心做节目的旧新闻片段，但我根本找不到喷泉。我当时都快放弃了，心想，你知道吗，我要去联系“办公室女士”的粉丝主页，因为大家会发布他们在斯克兰顿的照片。所以我联系了负责版务的妮基。然后她说：交给我吧。几个小时后，她回复我说：我找不到任何照片。我打了蒸汽镇购物中心的电话，联系到了一个人。他们对她问
if there's a fountain there. Why are all these people calling? You can ask if there's a fountain. Yeah. So they were like, well, we'll get your name and phone number and someone will contact you. And then an hour later, she just got a text message from them saying, no, we don't.
这里有没有喷泉感到非常困惑。为什么这么多人打电话来？你还可以问有没有喷泉吗？是的。所以他们就说，好吧，我们会记下你的名字和电话号码，会有人联系你的。然后一个小时后，她就收到了一条他们的短信，说：没有，我们没有。
All right. I love this story so much. I love that both of you women were calling the steentown mall ask if there's a fountain and the people are like, what do these ladies wanna do in a fountain? Why are they looking for a fountain so badly? I want to picture the person answering the phone like later that day, maybe they're on their break,
好了。我太喜欢这个故事了。我喜欢你们两个女士居然都打电话给蒸汽镇购物中心问有没有喷泉，然后那边的人心想，这些女士到底想在喷泉里干嘛？为什么她们这么拼命找喷泉？我想象着那天晚些时候接电话的那个人，也许他们正在休息，
you know, having a snack, they're with other co-workers and they're like, you guys getting calls, like later that day, maybe they're on their break, you know, having a snack, they're with other co-workers and they're like, you guys getting calls, like with people asking if we have a fountain? Like, what the hell? Thank you, Cassie. But Victoria, you are right. There is no fountain in the steentown mall.
吃着零食，跟其他同事在一起，然后他们会说，你们有接到电话吗，就像那天晚些时候，也许他们正在休息，吃着零食，跟其他同事在一起，然后他们会说，你们有接到电话吗，有人问我们有没有喷泉？搞什么鬼？谢谢你，卡西。不过维多利亚，你是对的。蒸汽镇购物中心根本没有喷泉。
Yes. Okay. Well, Angela, I have a mystery I wanna solve from this scene. And I'm calling it Ryan has glasses. Remember last episode, he was wearing his triad- Oh dear. Yes.
好的。好吧，安吉拉，我有个谜团想从这场戏里解开。我管它叫“瑞恩戴眼镜”。还记得上一集吗，他戴着他的三焦点镜——哦天哪。是的。
Well, now he's holding a pair of glasses. They never go on his face. After I saw this, I watched the whole episode waiting for those glasses to go on his face. But he's just gesturing with them. He's just got a pair of fake glasses. I don't know what he's going through. Ryan in the accessories.
好吧，现在他手里拿着一副眼镜。它们根本没戴在脸上。我看到这儿后，把整集都看完了，就等着那副眼镜戴到他脸上。但他只是拿着它们比划。他只是拿了一副假眼镜。我不知道他经历了什么。瑞恩戴上了配饰。
He's wanting to feel dignified or something. I guess so. Michael wants other people to shout out things they don't want to be teased about. And Dwight volunteers. He says, my nose is too small. And then he has a talking head where he says, the geometric proportions of my face are perfect in every way, but one, my nose is too small. I mean, it works. I can still smell things. I just have to be a lot closer than most people. And then Reynas Dwight does this little, like sniffy sniff.
他想找回点尊严什么的。我猜是的。迈克尔想让其他人大声说出他们不想被取笑的事情。德怀特自告奋勇。他说，我的鼻子太小了。然后他有一个采访镜头，他说，我脸部的几何比例在各个方面都是完美的，只有一个例外，我的鼻子太小了。我是说，这倒没问题。我还是能闻到东西。我只是得比大多数人靠得更近才行。然后雷恩饰演的德怀特做了一个这样的小动作，像吸了吸鼻子。
It's really cute, actually, I thought it was cute. We got so much mail about this, Angela. People really wanted to know if rain participated in this, the writing of this, or if it was a total surprise to him when he got the script. Well, here's what Hallstead said. He said asked Rain, if there was anything about him that people made fun of, or that he was ever sensitive about growing up, and Rain said, okay, my nose being small. And it actually worked as a really funny bit. Obviously, Rain is fine with his nose now, you know? Yes, but Paul Stead said they liked to reach out
其实挺可爱的，我觉得挺可爱的。我们收到了超多关于这个的信件，安吉拉。大家真的很想知道雷恩有没有参与这个环节的创作，或者当他拿到剧本时是不是完全吓了一跳。好吧，霍尔斯特德是这么说的。他说他问雷恩，有没有什么关于他自己的事情是以前经常被别人取笑的，或者是他在成长过程中比较敏感的，雷恩说，好吧，我的鼻子太小。这其实成了一个非常搞笑的包袱。很显然，雷恩现在对自己的鼻子已经释怀了，对吧？是的，不过保罗·斯特德说他们喜欢联系
to the actors to get things, that way it's better coming from the actor than the writer making something up that maybe I guess could hurt your feelings, right? Yeah, no, they were always really good about that. That's very funny. As the scene goes on, other people participate and I zoomed in on the Dryer Race Board at the end to see what Michael had written on the board under each person's name. The do not mock list has Michael, Koi Pond and Fountain, Dwight knows too small, Aaron, Orphan, Kevin, huge gut, Angela, Shrimpie, Meredith, sex with the terrorist. Shrimpie, shrimpie, so I was like, what? So I went to the script.
演员来获取这些素材，比起编剧凭空捏造一个可能会——我猜会伤害你感情的点，由演员自己说出来效果更好，对吧？对，没错，他们在这方面一直做得很好。太搞笑了。随着剧情推进，其他人也参与进来了，最后我把镜头拉近到干擦白板上，看看迈克尔在每个人的名字下面写了什么。免喷清单上有迈克尔：锦鲤池和喷泉；德怀特：鼻子太小；埃琳：孤儿；凯文：大肚子；安吉拉：小虾米；梅雷迪思：和恐怖分子睡觉。小虾米，小虾米，所以我就想，什么？于是我跑去查了剧本。
Shrimpie is not in the script. It says, for Angela Michael Wright's tiny bitch. And I think Steve, in the moment, just wrote Shrimpie. Well, there is a deleted scene for Aaron explaining why they wrote Orphan. That's right. Leaving the conference room, we are back with Pam and Andy. They are at their next sales call. They are with Keena Gifford, played by Amy Reed.
小虾米根本不在剧本里。剧本上写的是，给安吉拉的，迈克尔写的是“小贱人”。我觉得史蒂夫当时临时发挥，写成了“小虾米”。好吧，有一个删减片段是埃琳解释他们为什么写“孤儿”。没错。离开会议室，我们切回潘和安迪。他们正在进行下一场销售拜访。他们跟吉娜·吉福德在一起，由艾米·里德饰演。
Well, Angela, we know Amy Reed very well. I thought perhaps you'd like to give us the guest star breakdown on this one. Oh, I would love to. So Amy Reed, we knew her at this time as Amy Weaver. And she is just a dear friend of mine. And I've known her a long time. We met working at iOS. I think our bonding moment was the song Joleen came on. And she's from Oklahoma. And you know, my family's from Texas and Louisiana.
好吧，安吉拉，我们对艾米·里德非常熟悉。我想你可能愿意为我们做一下这一集的客串明星大盘点吧？哦，我太乐意了。所以艾米·里德，我们当时认识她时她叫艾米·韦弗。她真的是我非常亲密的朋友。我认识她很久了。我们在 iOS 工作时认识的。我想我们的破冰时刻是《多莉丝》（Jolene）这首歌响起来的时候。她是俄克拉荷马州人。你知道的，我的家人来自得克萨斯州和路易斯安那州。
And we both, without missing a beat, just started going, joe-ling, joe-ling, joe-ling, joe-ling. In our Southern accents. I just love her so much. She is a hilarious actress and phenomenal writer. She's still one of my dearest friends to this day. And I reached out to Amy and asked her if she could share her memories of being on the
我们俩几乎不约而同地开始唱起，乔琳，乔琳，乔琳，乔琳。用着我们的南方口音。我太爱她了。她是一位极其搞笑的女演员，也是个卓越的编剧。直到今天，她依然是我最亲密的朋友之一。我联系了艾米，问她能否分享一些在《办公室》
set of the office. And here's what she had to share. First of all, she said her scenes were only with Jenna and Ed in this super small abandoned office building. There wasn't a huge castor crew, so she really got to hang out, which is fun. She said one of the things she remembers is that Jenna was wearing a really huge baby bump. And it was making her go to the bathroom. And she went to the bathroom one time right before they called them back to set. And some very sweet but maybe a little too eager production assistant was knocking non-stop on the door while poor Jenna was trying to get the belly back on. Amy said, I only really appreciated how hot and heavy those suckers are many years later on a shoot where I had to be fake pregnant.
片场时的回忆。以下是她分享的内容。首先，她说她的戏份只跟珍娜和埃德在一个超级小的废弃办公楼里拍。没有庞大的剧组演职人员，所以她真的有很多时间闲逛，这很有趣。她说她记得的事情之一就是珍娜当时挺着一个超级大的假孕肚。这让她一直想上厕所。就在他们叫演员回片场之前，她刚去了一次厕所。有个非常甜美但可能有点太心急的制作助理在门外疯狂敲门，而可怜的珍娜正试图把那个肚子重新戴好。艾米说，多年后当我自己在一部戏里必须扮演假孕妇时，我才真正体会到那些大肚子到底有多热、多沉。
She said she would like everyone to know even fake pregnant women should not be rushed in the bathroom. That's the lesson here. I know you'd be happy. I know you're applauding. I am slow clapping that, Amy. Thank you. I feel so validated. Let me explain what you have on. It's not just a belly. So I was wearing for a reason I don't know tights. Yeah, so I've got underwear tights. Then on top of that, you have on like what's like almost a wetsuit with boy shorts. And that goes all the way up over your bra.
她说她想让所有人知道，哪怕是假孕妇也不应该在厕所里被催促。这就是本集的教训。我知道你会高兴的。我知道你在鼓掌。我为这个慢动作鼓掌，艾米。谢谢你。我觉得自己太被理解了。让我解释一下你身上穿的是什么。它可不仅仅是个假肚子。出于我不知道的原因，我当时还得穿紧身裤。是的，所以我里面有内衣和紧身裤。然后在那之上，你还得穿一件差不多像是带男孩短裤的潜水服似的东西。那玩意儿一直往上包过你的胸罩。
It's like a whole contraption. And then from there they can slide in different sized bellies. Then I had all my clothes on top of that but I also had on a microphone and a microphone pack with a wire taped to you. Yes. So to go to the bathroom I had to dismantle all of that. It was a good 10 minutes just to get undressed. Then I had to pee, then I had to put it all on. Again, it was like 20 minutes. If I said I need to go to the bathroom, that was a 20 minute break because it was really difficult and frustrating and no one seemed to get it.
这就像是一整套复杂的机关。然后从那里他们可以塞进不同尺寸的假肚子。接着我所有的衣服都穿在最外面，但不仅如此，我还戴着麦克风，带着连着一根粘在你身上的电线的麦克风包。是的。所以要想上厕所，我必须把所有这些东西全都拆下来。光是脱衣服就得整整 10 分钟。然后我得撒尿，接着还得把它全穿回去。再来一次，大概得 20 分钟。如果我说我需要去上厕所，那意味着 20 分钟的休息时间，因为这真的又困难又让人沮丧，而且似乎没人能理解这一点。
And I really, like I asked Alicia, I was like, Alicia, is it worth like gathering the production team together and sort of like taking them through all the layers because they expect me to pee in the same amount of time that I always pee, but I'm wearing so many more elements. And maybe there's like a workshop we can do. To show them. Yes.
我真的——就像我问艾莉西亚的那样，我说，艾莉西亚，把制作团队召集起来，带他们过一遍所有的夹层是不是很有必要？因为他们期望我能像平时一样在相同的时间内上完厕所，但我身上穿的部件要多得多。也许我们可以办个工作坊来向他们展示。是的。
And I actually think Angela, correct me if I'm wrong. Wasn't there a day where Kelly can't leave our first AD, put it on and wore it? Yes, because you were like, someone else needs to experience this. Please, I'm begging you. And so she put it on, you know, years later I would have to wear the same thing, and I feel like you paved the way with our crew about what to expect. I know, but you know what? It was a tough road. It was a tough paving.
其实我觉得，安吉拉，如果我记错的话请纠正我。是不是有一天，第一副导演凯莉·坎特把那套东西穿在身上试了试？是的，因为当时你说：得让其他人也体验一下这玩意儿。求求你们了，我求你们了。于是她就穿上了，你知道的，多年后我也得穿同样的东西，我觉得你为我们的剧组打好了前站，让他们知道会面临什么。我知道，但你知道吗？那真是一段艰难的路。那是一条披荆斩棘的路。
Well, after all these years, that's the first thing Amy remembered to share with me. Amy, thank you. Thank you. I'm so touched. She went on to say, Jenna and Ed and I were jammed into a tiny office, and the director Reggie and the crew were outside the door on the other side. And at some point during downtime between takes, Jenna and I got really chatted with each other. And I guess we were kind of leaving Ed
好吧，历经这么多年，那是艾米唯一记得跟我分享的事。艾米，谢谢你。谢谢你。我太感动了。她接着说，詹娜、埃德和我被塞进了一个小办公室里，导演雷吉和剧组人员在门外，也就是另一边。在拍摄间隙的某个时候，詹娜和我开始聊得很投机。我想我们大概把埃德
out of the conversation with very little room to jump in. And he finally just interrupted and said, do you two know each other? Because you admit Amy through me and we had become all a group of friends. Yeah, yeah. The last thing Amy shared was this. One random thing that made a huge impression on me that day
晾在对话之外了，他根本没多少插话的空间。他最后终于打断我们并说：“你们俩认识吗？”因为你是通过我认识艾米的，我们大家曾结成了一个朋友圈。对，对。艾米分享的最后一件事是这个。那天有一件随机的小事给我留下了极其深刻的印象
was when Jenna invited me to her trailer for lunch. As we sat there chatting, it somehow came up about the beginning of you and hers friendship. Jenna shared about the transition you guys had by being on the cast of the office, how you two really bonded over going from inconsistent acting careers to suddenly being in the limelight and the impact and weight of being on the office and the adjustment to that and how you two were together through all of it.
，那就是詹娜邀请我去她的房车吃午饭。当我们坐在那儿聊天时，不知怎么就聊到了你俩友谊的开端。詹娜分享了你们俩作为《办公室》演员所经历的转变，你们俩是如何真正建立起深厚情谊的——从不稳定的演艺生涯，突然之间置身于聚光灯下，身处《办公室》所带来的影响和分量，以及对这种状况的适应，你们俩是如何携手度过这一切的。
Through that transition, you balanced earnest humility and the thrill of being on the number one comedy. Wow. Now I'm like crying. you balanced earnest humility and the thrill of being on the number one comedy. Wow, now I'm like crying. Now I'm like really moved. I know. Yeah, I mean, that was true. I can't imagine having to have done that without you, Angela. Oh, lady. It was overwhelming. It was all of your professional dreams coming true, but all the ways that you don't think that that is going to impact your life in weird ways, you know, your face on television every week. And what that does, how it changes different relationships or friendships, how your time is not your
历经那种转变，你兼具了真诚的谦逊和置身于头号喜剧之中的兴奋。哇。现在我都快哭了。你兼具了真诚的谦逊和置身于头号喜剧之中的兴奋。哇，现在我都快哭了。现在我真的好感动。我知道。对，我是说，那是真的。安杰拉，我无法想象如果没有你，我该怎么熬过这一切。哦，天哪。这太让人招架不住了。这实现了你所有的职业梦想，但同时也伴随着各种你意想不到的方式在奇怪的方面影响你的生活，你知道的，每周你的脸都会出现在电视上。而这会带来什么，它如何改变不同的关系或友谊，当你参演电视剧时，你的时间便不再属于
own when you are on a television show, the long hours, but then all of the additional promotional work that takes up your weekends and how you can't go to things anymore and to have someone to go through that with and navigate that with. And you're so excited. But then the midwesterner and me would always feel like very shy about it. And I think we had that in common. I mean, she really nailed it. I know.
你自己了，漫长的工作时间，还有占用你周末的所有额外宣传工作，以及你再也不能去参加各种活动，能有一个人陪你一起经历并应对这一切。你感到无比兴奋。但另一方面，我骨子里的中西部人性格总是对此感到非常害羞。我想我们有这个共同点。我是说，她真的说得很准。我知道。
I thought what great observations from her day on set. Yeah. Well, you know, I feel the same way, lady. My gosh, how would I gotten through you know the last 18 years? Oh my word without your friendship. Oh my gosh 18. I have one last fun tidbit about the scene Warren reminded me of it and I went and looked for it immediately There is a photo of our daughter Isabel in a frame just over Amy's shoulder. If you go to 11 minutes 35 seconds, you can see Isabel in the little silver frame.
我觉得她对片场那一天的观察真是太棒了。对啊。嗯，你知道的，我有同感，天哪。如果没有你的友谊，我真不知道自己是怎么挺过过去的，你知道的，过去的18年？噢，天哪，竟然18年了。关于那个场景，我还有一个最后有趣的趣闻，沃伦提醒了我，我马上就去找了。艾米肩膀上方的一个相框里，有我们女儿伊莎贝尔的照片。如果你拉到11分35秒，就能看到小银框里的伊莎贝尔。
She's smiling so big, she's in her car seat. I love that Phil Shade did that for us. It just, oh my gosh, warmed my heart so much. I saw it too. Oh, oh, and one last thing. I know I've had a lot to say about this scene. So Miss Gifford and Andy Bond over this birthing teacher named Miss Janet.
她笑得好灿烂，正坐在她的安全座椅里。我真喜欢菲尔·谢德为我们做了这个。它真的，哦天哪，让我的心感到无比温暖。我也看到了。哦，哦，还有最后一件事。我知道我对这个场景有太多的感慨了。吉福德小姐和安迪因为一个名叫珍妮特小姐的生育老师而增进了感情。
Well, Janet is my sister's name. Hmm. That's so sweet. So there you go. That's everything that I had for that scene. Well, I think we should take a break. And when we come back, we're going to talk about how you eat like a squirrel, Angela. Okay, great. We are back, and we are still in the conference room. People are still talking about the things that bother them,
嗯，珍妮特是我姐姐的名字。嗯。太贴心了。所以就是这样。这就是我对那个场景所有的了解了。好吧，我想我们该休息一下了。当我们回来时，我们要聊聊你吃东西怎么跟松鼠一样，安杰拉。好的，太棒了。我们回来了，我们依然在会议室里。大家还在讨论那些让他们烦心的事情，
and Angela, you do not like it when people say you eat like a squirrel. Mm-hmm. You don't care for that. I don't care for that, and also, I'm afraid someone's gonna throw me around like a football because I'm so petite. Mm-hmm. Aaron is going to interrupt this meeting, and let Michael know that someone has called to inform them that one of the Koi died and they want him to pay for it.
而安杰拉，你很不喜欢别人说你吃东西像松鼠。嗯哼。你不在乎这个。我才不在乎呢，而且，我还担心有人会把我像橄榄球一样扔来扔去，因为我太娇小了。嗯哼。艾伦将要打断这次会议，并通知迈克尔说，有人打电话来告知他们其中一条锦鲤死了，他们想让他赔偿。
It's going to be $300. Aren't Koi like crazy expensive? Yeah, they are. And Hallstad shared that they had pitched around in the writer's room a kind of extension of this storyline because they found out that some koi can like cost as much as $2,000. So at one point the koi that Michael killed was gonna be worth $2,000 and that Michael was going to pay for it.
这要300美元。锦鲤不是很贵得离谱吗？对，确实很贵。而且霍尔斯塔德分享说，他们在编剧室里曾构思过这个故事情节的一种延伸，因为他们发现有些锦鲤的价格甚至高达2000美元。所以一度迈克尔弄死的锦鲤价值将达到2000美元，而且迈克尔打算为此赔钱。
He was gonna get it because he was gonna want to see a $2,000 fish. And then back at the office, he was going to cook it in the toaster oven and eat it. No. Yes, this was the pitch. But that ultimately Michael was going to chicken out and he was just going to throw it away. And Hallstad said, by the time they got to the end of this pitch, they were like, you know what, it's disturbing. We're going to, how about the coy is just $300 and there's no eating of the coy or throwing it away. Yes. And Hallstad said, I'm very happy we changed that. Well, you know, Michael wouldn't have thrown it away. If he didn't eat it, he would have had a proper burial for it.
他打算把它弄到手，因为他想看看2000块钱的鱼。然后回到办公室后，他打算把它放在小烤箱里烤了吃。不会吧。是的，这就是当时的构思。但最终迈克尔会临阵退缩，他只是打算把它扔掉。霍尔斯塔德说，等他们把这个构思讨论到最后时，他们觉得：“你知道吗，这太让人不安了。我们要把……锦鲤改成只要300美元，而且没有吃锦鲤或把它扔掉的情节。”没错。而且霍尔斯塔德说：“我很高兴我们改了。”好吧，你知道的，迈克尔才不会把它扔掉呢。如果他不吃它，他会为它举行一场像样的葬礼的。
That's most likely, yes. And there would have been a coy funeral. Yes, and then maybe Creed would have digged it up and eaten it. Ah, of course. I did love when Creed was like, oh man, you're paying way too much for worms. Who's your worm guy? Who's your worm guy?
那是最有可能的，对。而且还会有一场锦鲤葬礼。对，然后也许克里德会把它挖出来吃掉。啊，理所当然。我确实很喜欢克里德说“哦，天哪，你们买虫子花大钱了。谁是你的买虫人？”的时候。谁是你的买虫人？
So funny. Put that on a shirt. Jim is going to get Michael aside and say, I have a strategy. I think maybe you should make fun of yourself for falling into the quay pond. Yeah, that will diffuse everyone else, right? Yeah, they won't be able to tell jokes because you've covered it. So, Michael's gonna try it. He's like, all right, I'll try it.
太搞笑了。把这印到衬衫上。吉姆把迈克尔拉到一旁说：“我有个策略。我觉得也许你应该拿自己掉进锦鲤池这件事来自嘲。”对，这能化解其他所有人的情绪，对吧？对，他们就没法开玩笑了，因为你已经把这事包揽了。所以，迈克尔要试一试。他说：“好吧，我试试。”
And at first, it goes well. And then it doesn't. He goes too far. He goes too far. And he knows he's going too far. This was such a brilliant performance. It's like that thing when you're like talking to someone and you know that moment you went past where you should have stopped.
一开始，进展顺利。然后就不对劲了。他过头了。他过头了。而且他知道自己过头了。这表演真是太精彩了。就像那种情况：当你跟某人说话时，你知道那一刻你已经超过了本该停下来的界限。
And in your own brain, you're like, stop, stop, but you can't. Yes, and he just keeps talking. He keeps saying embarrassing things about his life that aren't even about the koi pond. Well, Warren shared with us that this was one of his favorite comedy bits. And he said when Michael goes too far with it, they had even more pitch, Jenna. They had even more jokes in the pipeline here. He said he and Halstead loved writing this runner. Here were some that didn't make it in the show. Are you ready?
而在你自己的脑子里，你会想“停下，停下”，但你做不到。是的，他还在滔滔不绝。他一直在说关于自己人生的尴尬事情，那些甚至跟锦鲤池毫无关系的事。好吧，沃伦跟我们分享说，这是他最喜欢的喜剧桥段之一。他说，当迈克尔在这件事上做得太过火时，他们甚至还有更多的构思，詹娜。他们在这里准备了更多的笑料。他说他和霍尔斯塔德很喜欢写这条支线。以下是一些没能进入正片的笑料。准备好了吗？
I'm ready. I can't listen to talk radio when I drive because I get scared that someone else is in the car. Okay. Then there was another one where Michael locks himself in a dog cage at Kmart. No one could get him out. He was stuck. And they had to call the fire department.
我准备好了。我开车时不能听谈话广播，因为我害怕车里还有别人。好吧。然后还有另一个场景，迈克尔把自己锁在凯玛特的狗笼子里。谁也弄不出来他。他被困住了。他们不得不叫消防队。
Okay. Then there was a take when Michael goes so far and cuts so deep at himself that he makes himself cry, and Warren said Steve's performance was so phenomenal, it was his favorite take, he fought really hard, but too many people disagreed. They said it was too depressing and Warren lost the battle, so it ends with the... Who's there?
好吧。还有一个镜头是，迈克尔太过分了，对自己的挖苦如此深刻，以至于把自己弄哭了。沃伦说史蒂夫的表演太惊艳了，这是他最喜欢的镜头，他极力争取，但反对的人太多了。他们说这太压抑了，沃伦输了这场争论，所以最后以……“谁在那儿？”结束。
Wow. This was definitely one of those scenes where we would go to the candy bag. They would always have extra stuff for scenes like this. And I know we say this a lot, you guys, but Steve is so amazing, because he could dial it up or dial it down or cry,
哇。这绝对是那种我们会走向糖果袋的场景。为这样的场景，他们总是准备有额外的零食。我知道我们经常这么说，伙计们，但史蒂夫实在是太棒了，因为他能把情绪调高或调低，或者哭泣，
or just, he could do anything. He was so impressive. I would lose myself. I've said this before. I'd be like, oh crap, I'm supposed to be reacting as Angela Martin. And instead, I was just there like, oh my gosh, Steve is crushing it.
或者仅仅是，他什么都能演。他太令人印象深刻了。我会忘乎所以。我以前说过。我会想：“哦糟了，我应该以安杰拉·马丁的身份做出反应。”而相反，我只是站在那儿想：“哦天哪，史蒂夫演得太绝了。”
I wish I could have been there. I would have loved to have watched this. That was maybe one of the things that was so fun about rewatching this episode was that I was really watching this as a fan because I wasn't there. So I don't have memories of what else went on or what got cut. I'm just watching it.
我真希望当时能在现场。我肯定会很乐意看这个。重看这一集最有意思的事情之一也许就是，我真的是以粉丝的视角在看，因为我当时不在场。所以我没有其他事情发生或者什么被剪掉的记忆。我只是在看。
It's great. Same. Same. I think that's why I got so tickled when Andy says, looks like someone's got a case of the definitely. I wasn't there when you guys did that. Yeah. Well, now, Angela, I've got a fan question for you
太棒了。我也是。我也是。我想这就是为什么当安迪说“看起来有人得了‘绝对’病”时，我会觉得那么好笑。你们拍那段的时候我不在。对。好吧，现在，安杰拉，我有一个粉丝问题要问你，
because you are in the break room and you are eating a nut. Heather C from Leeds in the UK said, Angela, what of my favorite Angela moments ever is the bit where you eat like a squirrel in the break room? Also the part where you wrap your packaging back up, cracks me up so much. How did you come up with this bit exactly?
因为你在休息室里，而且你在吃坚果。来自英国利兹的希瑟·C说：“安杰拉，我最喜欢的安杰拉时刻之一，就是你在休息室里像松鼠一样吃东西的那段。还有你把包装纸重新包起来的那部分，让我笑得前仰后合。这个桥段到底是怎么想出来的？”
Did you perhaps watch a lot of videos of squirrels eating? Ha, ha, ha, that's hilarious. Well, thank you for appreciating my squirrel eating performance. You know, honestly, I didn't watch any videos. I just, you know, I've seen a squirrel eat and I've used my own personal life observation. And just so you know, the stage direction in the script for the scene was Meredith, Kevin, Angela, and Oscar sit at tables. Angela, nods at an almond holding it with two hands like a squirrel.
你难道是看了很多松鼠吃东西的视频吗？哈哈哈，太搞笑了。好吧，谢谢你欣赏我模仿松鼠吃东西的表演。说实话，我真的没有看任何视频。我只是，你知道的，我见过松鼠吃东西，我借鉴了自己的个人生活观察。顺便让你们知道，剧本里关于这个场景的舞台指示是：“梅雷迪思、凯文、安杰拉和奥斯卡坐在桌旁。安杰拉点头对着一颗杏仁，像松鼠一样用两只手捧着它。”
So I knew I had to hold it with two hands just the way I'm doing it. And then I just ate it the way I thought a squirrel would eat it. And then in the script it goes on to say, she puts the rest of her almond back into Saran wrap. So that was in the script, but how I folded it and did it, you know, it was just me sort of playing in the moment. I had so much fun doing that and we kept laughing. Like Brian and Oscar, we all kept cracking up.
所以我知道我必须像我正在做的那样用两只手捧着它。然后我就按照我认为松鼠会吃的方式把它吃掉了。接着剧本上写道：“她把剩下的杏仁放回保鲜膜里。”所以那是剧本里写好的，但我怎么把它折叠起来并完成这个动作的，你知道的，那只是我在当下即兴发挥。我演那个演得太开心了，我们一直在笑。就像布赖恩和奥斯卡，我们所有人都一直笑得前俯后仰。
Well, as your BFF, I will go on record to say that you do not actually eat like that. We all know you bite right into the string cheese. Oh, yeah. I'm not holding it with two hands. No, I know it. I'm going to chomp at it. You're not stringing it or anything, I'm not holding it with two hands, not I know. I'm gonna chomp at it. You're not stringing it or anything. You're just eating it.
好吧，作为你的闺蜜，我要正式声明，你实际上并不是那样吃东西的。我们都知道你直接咬那根手撕干酪。哦，对。我才不是用双手捧着呢。不，我知道。我会大口咬下去。你根本不是把它撕成一条一条的之类的，我才没有用双手捧着呢，我知道。我会大口咬下去。你根本不是把它撕成一条一条的。你就是直接吃。
But you do often wrap up the second half of whatever you haven't eaten. This is true. That is true. This is true. If you open my fridge right now, there's like four grapes wrapped up in a little piece of tin foil.
但你确实经常把没吃完的那一部分东西给包起来。这倒不假。那是真的。这倒是真的。如果你现在打开我的冰箱，里面大概有四颗用一小块锡箔纸包起来的葡萄。
You're gonna eat those later. I will. So listen, back in the meeting with Pam and Andy. Andy is really gets a little out of control. He's like smothering Pam's belly with his face. Well, they've just finally decided to lean into it. Yeah, fine. We're a couple. This is our baby to try to make the sale. But we learn a lot about Andy in this moment. We do. And afterwards, Pam says, you know, that was great. But maybe you took it a little far. And he's like, yeah, yeah, it was maybe the belly kissing was a little much.
你一会儿还要吃那些。我会的。所以听着，回到帕姆和安迪开会的场景。安迪真的有点失控了。他把脸直往帕姆的肚子上蹭。好吧，他们终于决定顺其自然了。好吧，行吧。我们是一对。这是我们的宝宝，为了谈成这笔生意。但我们在此时对安迪有了很多了解。确实如此。之后，帕姆说：“你知道的，那挺好。但也许你有点过头了。”而他却说：“对，对，也许亲肚子有点太过分了。”
And he reveals a couple of things. One, he reveals that it was nice for him to pretend for a minute that he was part of a couple with a baby on the way. Oh, that broke my heart. I know. And then he also reveals that maybe he has a little crush on Aaron. Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Well guess what? Meredith's roommate is friends with the night janitor at the office building where Michael fell and she's got a copy of the security footage. Yes she does. Everyone is going to gather around Meredith's computer and we are going to see
接着他透露了几件事。第一，他透露假装自己是一对即将迎来宝宝的伴侣，这让他觉得有一会儿感觉挺美好的。哦，这太让我心碎了。我知道。然后他还透露，也许他对艾伦有点小迷恋。嗯。嗯。嗯。好吧，你猜怎么着？梅雷迪思的室友跟迈克尔摔倒的那栋办公大楼的夜班清洁工是朋友，她有一份监控录像的拷贝。没错，她有。所有人都将聚集在梅雷迪思的电脑周围，我们将看到
Michael fall into the Koi Pond. We got so many fan questions about the fall into the Koi Pond, and we're going to do our best to break it down for you. Starting with Callie B. from Rogers, Arkansas, who asked, where was the security footage of Steve falling into the pond filmed? Randy told us that we shot the Koi pond just down the street from our studios. They were a neon sign manufacturing business called Knights of Neon. This business has operated for over 30 years
迈克尔掉进锦鲤池。我们收到了许多关于掉进锦鲤池的粉丝提问，我们将尽力为你剖析。从阿肯色州罗杰斯的卡利·B开始，她问：史蒂夫掉进池塘的监控录像是在哪里拍摄的？兰迪告诉我们，我们拍摄锦鲤池的地方就在我们工作室的这条街往下走不远。那里有一家名为“霓虹骑士”的霓虹灯标牌制造企业。这家企业已经营了30多万年
and they make custom neon signs for commercial use. I really hope their logo is like a night and like metal armor, holding up like a shield. Knights of Neon. Oh, well, it's spelled N-I-G-H-T-S of Neon. Oh, boo! Don't you think I'm kidding?
不对，运营了30多年，他们为商业用途制作定制霓虹灯标牌。我真心希望他们的标志是一个穿着金属铠甲的骑士，举着一面盾牌。霓虹骑士。哦，对了，它是拼作N-I-G-H-T-S of Neon。哦，嘘！你以为我在开玩笑吗？
I'm kidding, I'm kidding. This company, Knights of Neon, had a really big empty warehouse. And that's why we picked it. We rented it out for a whole week. And Michael Gallenberg and his construction coordinator, Tim James, they started by laying down like a waterproof liner over the entire floor of the warehouse. Then they built a coipont on top of it that held a thousand gallons of filtered water. And then they made the walkways on top of it that held a thousand gallons of filtered water,
我在开玩笑，开玩笑，开玩笑。这家名为“霓虹骑士”的公司有一个非常大的空仓库。这就是我们选中它的原因。我们把它租下来整整一个星期。迈克尔·盖伦伯格和他的施工统筹蒂姆·詹姆斯，首先在整个仓库的地板上铺了一层防水衬垫。然后他们在上面建了一个锦鲤池，里面盛有一千加仑过滤水。接着他们在上面搭建了走道，里面盛有一千加仑过滤水，
and then they made the walkways on top of it. They also then set up two cameras, Reggie really wanted like this motorized surveillance camera that would sort of sweep the lobby back and forth. And so Matt's own created this effect by using a tripod with a fluid head mounted on top of a tall ladder. So they made this fakie, sweeping security camera.
然后他们在上面搭建了走道。他们随后还设置了两台摄像机，雷吉非常想要那种马达驱动的监控摄像机，可以来回扫视大厅。于是马特的团队通过使用一个三脚架制造了这种效果，三脚架配有一个安装在高梯子顶部的液压云台。所以他们制作了这个虚假的、扫视状的监控摄像机。
I guess this sweeping shot is best seen in the deleted scenes around four minutes, nine seconds. Oh yeah, go to the deleted scenes for this episode. It's the last one. It's the whole entire footage of Michael falling in. And when I watched it, I was like, oh wow, I didn't realize how long Steve was in the water. I mean, they really went for it.
我想这个扫视镜头在4分9秒左右的删减片段中能看得最清楚。哦对，去看这一集的删减片段。那是最后一个。那是迈克尔掉进去的整段完整录像。当我看到它时，我想：“哦，天哪，我以前没意识到史蒂夫在水里待了那么久。”我是说，他们真的是全力以赴。
Well, I guess we added another stationary non-moving B camera that was angled a little bit more at the front. Derek Carver was our B camera operator that day. And the footage that you end up seeing on this tape that everyone's watching is that B camera footage, the still footage. Alright, next question. This one comes from Braylin' M in Seattle, Washington. Were there actually COI in the pond that Michael falls in?
好吧，我想我们还添加了一台固定的、不动的B机，角度稍微朝向正面一点。德里克·卡弗那天是我们的B机摄影师。而你最终在这段大家都在看的录像带上看到的画面，就是那个B机的镜头，固定镜头。好的，下一个问题。这个来自华盛顿州西雅图的布雷林·M。迈克尔掉进去的那个池塘里真的有锦鲤吗？
Yes! Yes, Randy told us that we went with our usual animal training company, which was Bob Dunn's animal rentals in Silmar, California. They do it all, clearly. They do it all, clearly. They do. The head trainer there is Denise Sanders, but we had to also employ a special Koi Wrangler named Mike Long. What was Kelly Cantley thinking? She's had a fruit fly Wrangler, she's had a Koi Wrangler, several cat wranglers. Fascinating. They filled up the coy pond with water several days
有！是的，兰迪告诉我们，我们找的是惯常合作的动物驯养公司，也就是加州希尔马的鲍勃·邓恩动物租赁公司。他们显然什么都做。他们显然什么都做。他们确实做。那里的首席驯养师是丹尼斯·桑德斯，但我们还必须雇用一个名叫迈克·朗的专门锦鲤驯养员。凯利·坎特利当时是怎么想的？她雇过果蝇驯养员、锦鲤驯养员、好几个猫咪驯养员。太迷人了。他们在几天
in advance because they had to let the chlorine evaporate from the water. They did a careful pH balance, all of that. Randy said the coy were very expensive. And before they put the coy into the pond, they did a test with some goldfish, just to make sure. So the goldfish they were like, you know, when the king has a tester, eat the food first. Yeah.
提前把水注入锦鲤池，因为他们必须让水中的氯挥发掉。他们做了细致的pH值平衡，诸如此类。兰迪说锦鲤非常昂贵。在他们把锦鲤放入池塘之前，他们用一些金鱼做了一个测试，以防万一。所以那些金鱼，它们就像是，你知道的，当国王有试毒员先吃食物一样。对。
So those little goldfish, they lived. Well, thank God they lived. I get it. The koi went in. He said that we used 28 koi that were up to two feet long. They're very big. And that the total cost for the fish, the holding tanks, the pumps, the filters, and all the labor was $12,000.
所以那些小金鱼活了下来。好吧，谢天谢地它们活下来了。我懂了。锦鲤进去了。他说我们用了28条锦鲤，体长达两英尺。它们非常大。而且鱼、蓄水箱、水泵、过滤器的总成本，以及所有的人工费用是12,000美元。
Wow, that's a pricey coy pond. Well, when we started filming, Hallstead shared that when they put the koi in the pond, they immediately all swam under the steps that went over the middle of the koi pond. Yeah. And I guess they were in a new environment. And so they kind of go and hide, they check it out,
哇，那真是一个昂贵的锦鲤池。好吧，当我们开始拍摄时，霍尔斯塔德分享说，当他们把锦鲤放入池塘时，它们立刻全都游到了穿过锦鲤池中央的台阶下方。对。我想它们是在一个新环境中。所以它们某种程度上就去躲起来了，它们在观察情况，
and it takes them a bit to get comfortable and then to swim out from their hiding place. The coy wrangler told Halstead and Warren that they had to wait for the coy to settle and come out before they could do the first take. Aww, those guys were just standing there waiting for the coy. Yeah, so someone probably made an announcement, guys, we're going to take five and let the coy get ready Waiting on the coy. I've got another fan question now from Nina D in Washington
过了一会儿它们才适应下来，然后从藏身处游出来。锦鲤驯养员告诉霍尔斯塔德和沃伦，他们必须等锦鲤安定下来并游出来之后，才能拍第一个镜头。啊，那些家伙就站在那儿等着锦鲤。对，所以某人可能发布了一个通知：“伙计们，我们要休息五分钟，让锦鲤准备好。”等待锦鲤。现在我这儿还有另一个来自华盛顿州尼娜·D的粉丝问题：
How many takes did you do of Michael falling into the pond? Randy said they really hoped the answer would be one Hmm, but the answer is two. Uh oh. I think we should mention that Steve did not have a stunt double. Steve actually fell into the pond. That is very clear if you go to deleted scenes. When he got out from doing it the first time, they went over and they checked that sweeping camera time. They went over and they checked that sweeping camera that they had set up to look like security footage. It had missed all of the action. It swept past him and then he fell and then it swept back. It missed it all. So they had to ask Steve to dry off and do it again. Warren shared that he could tell Steve was, you know, bummed out because he had fallen
迈克尔掉进池塘的镜头你们拍了几个镜头？兰迪说他们真的希望答案是一个，嗯，但答案是两个。噢不。我想我们应该提一下，史蒂夫没有替身。史蒂夫是真的掉进了池塘里。如果你去看删减片段，这一点非常清楚。当他第一次拍完爬出来时，他们走过去查看那个扫视镜头的回放。他们走过去查看他们设置的、用来冒充监控录像的那个扫视镜头。它错过了所有的动作。它从他身旁扫过去，然后他才掉下去，接着它又扫了回来。全错过了。所以他们不得不要求史蒂夫擦干身子再来一次。沃伦分享说，他能看出史蒂夫当时，你知道的，心里挺沮丧的，因为他已经掉进
into the coin pond and splashed about and now he was going to have to do it again. And he said, Steve asked out loud, if anyone would believe this was even possible. And Paul Lieberstein, Warren's brother, who was there at the time, pointed at Warren and said, oh, it's possible. Oh, no. And I guess somehow up to this point, Steve was unaware that it had actually happened to Warren. And Warren said, Steve just looked at him and said, wow, Warren said that that was very generous because he could tell clearly there were many thoughts running through Steve's brain, which he chose not to say. And he just said, wow, and then they all started laughing.
锦鲤池里扑腾了一番，现在他不得不重来一次。他说，史蒂夫大声问，是否有人会相信这居然是可能的。而当时在场的保罗·利伯斯坦（沃伦的弟弟）指着沃伦说：“哦，这完全可能。”哦，不。我想不知怎么的，直到这个时候，史蒂夫还不知道这事确实在沃伦身上发生过。沃伦说，史蒂夫只是看着他说了句“哇”。沃伦说这表现得非常大度，因为他能明显看出当时史蒂夫脑子里闪过了很多想法，但他选择不说。他只是说了句“哇”，然后大家就都笑了起来。
And Warren said, he knows a lot of people have said this, but it is true that Steve truly was the nicest. Wow. Can you imagine Steve looking at you and going, wow! Okay, all right. All right then. Well,
沃伦说，他知道很多人都说过这话，但事实确实如此，史蒂夫真的是最好的人。哇。你能想象史蒂夫看着你说“哇”吗？好吧，好吧。那就这样吧。那么，
Halstead shared that after Steve fell into the pond, it caused all the koi to hide again. So Steve dried off, but then they had to wait for them to come out again. Holstead also shared he doesn't even think you can see any of the Koi. Listen, when I watch the deleted scene, it's like black and white kind of security camp, right? It's supposed to. I couldn't really see the Koi. I don't know why I'm whispering that.
霍尔斯塔德分享说，在史蒂夫掉进池塘后，这导致所有的锦鲤又全都躲了起来。所以史蒂夫擦干了身子，但接着他们不得不再次等待它们游出来。霍尔斯塔德还分享说，他甚至不认为你能看到任何锦鲤。听着，当我观看那个删减片段时，那是那种黑白画面的监控摄像机，对吧？本该如此。我其实看不清锦鲤。我不知道我为什么要压低声音说这个。
I'm doing that thing. My mom does. Where you whisper bad news. Yeah. Yeah. I didn't see that going. Yeah. Well, I guess on this second take,
我在做那种我妈会做的事。就是说坏消息时压低声音。对。对。我没料到会这样。好吧，我想在第二个镜头里，
they did get it on the sweeping camera, but like I said, they didn't even end up using that part of the footage anyway. Now, this all leads me to our final fan question about this. From Logan Z and Columbus, Ohio, when everyone is watching the clip of Michael falling in on the computer, did you actually get to watch the video or are you guys just pretending? It was a little bit of a combo. So they had some of the footage of Steve falling in,
他们确实用扫视镜头拍到了，但就像我说的，反正他们最后也没有使用那部分镜头。现在，这一切把我引向了我们关于这件事的最后一个粉丝问题。来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市的洛根·Z：当所有人在电脑上观看迈克尔掉下去的片段时，你们是真的看到了那段视频，还是你们只是在假装？这其实是一点点结合。所以他们手头有一些史蒂夫掉进去的镜头画面，
and they had it on a little monitor that they showed us. It actually wasn't on Meredith's computer, but they did show it to the cast before we started rolling so we could see what happened. Mm-hmm. And then we all gather around Meredith's desk and we just sort of faked it. Yes, Randy said that they burned it in to the computer screen with special effects
而且他们把它放在一个小监视器上给我们看。其实那不在梅雷迪思的电脑上，但在我们开始开拍之前，他们确实把它放给演员们看了，这样我们就能看到发生了什么。嗯哼。然后我们全员围在梅雷迪思的桌子周围，只是假装在看。是的，兰迪说他们是用特效把画面烧录到电脑屏幕上的，
that that came later. And I think some of that is because they had quite decided exactly what they were going to use yet right when you guys shot your scene. I guess we should probably explain that as they're watching this video, everyone notices that as Michael's falling in, Jim, like Leanne's back. I mean, hard. Completely, it's like he's stepping out of the way, like no, no, no, no, no, don't take me with you. He does not try to grab Michael,
那是后来才加上去的。而且我想部分原因是因为就在你们拍这个场景时，他们还没完全决定好到底要用哪些镜头。我想我们或许应该解释一下，当他们看着这段视频时，每个人都注意到，在迈克尔掉下去的同时，吉姆整个人往后仰。我是说，狠狠地往后。完全就像他在闪开一样，好像在说“不，不，不，不，别把我一块儿带下去”。他根本没有试图去抓迈克尔，
he does not try to stop it, and everyone is now piling on Jim. They're like, yeah, Jim, you could've caught Michael. What the hell? We got a fan question from Kelly Asson, Portland, Maine, who is wondering, like, was Jim really at fault for Michael falling in the quay pond? You know, it's not like he bumped him.
他根本没有试图阻止它，现在所有人都在指责吉姆。他们会说：“得了吧，吉姆，你本可以接住迈克尔的。搞什么鬼？”我们收到了来自缅因州波特兰的凯莉·阿森的一个粉丝问题，她想知道：吉姆真的该为迈克尔掉进锦鲤池负首要责任吗？你知道的，他又没撞他。
Kelly says, what was Jim supposed to do if he'd grabbed Michael, maybe they would have both fallen in. Thoughts? Thoughts. It's sort of an interesting character assessment of your personal character. It's like fight, flight, or freeze, right? So, yeah. So Michael's falling. Let's say you and I are walking over a coin pond and you're next to me and you start to fall. I would hope my first instinct would be to grab for you. I mean, I do that with my kids.
凯莉说，吉姆当时该怎么做？如果他抓了迈克尔，也许他们两个都会掉进去。大家怎么看？大家怎么看。这算是对你个人品格的一个有趣的性格评估。就像是战斗、逃跑还是僵住，对吧？所以，对。所以迈克尔正在往下掉。比方说你和我正走在一个锦鲤池边，你挨着我，然后你开始往下掉。我希望我的第一直觉是伸手去抓你。我是说，我对我的孩子就会这样。
You know how that mom instinct kicks in? Like you're at a soccer game and there's a ball that goes crazy towards the stands and you grab your kid out of the way. I mean, it's just like a reflex. Lady, this just made me remember something that happened in a real life. What? so
你知道那种妈妈的本能是怎么被激发出来的吗？就像你在看一场足球比赛，有个球疯狂地飞向看台，你会把你的孩子拉开。我是说，这就像是一种条件反射。天哪，这让我想起了现实生活中发生的一件事。什么？所以
I'm just remembering those I was in the kitchen and Lee walked in the kitchen and he was soaking wet Just like this just like he's soaking wet like Like what happened? I know, I know where this is going. What happened? And he was like, I found the swimming pool. I'm like, you fell in the swimming pool, how? So when our daughter was little, she used to like it when Lee would fake throw her in the swimming pool.
我刚想起来，有一次我在厨房里，李走进了厨房，他浑身湿透了。就像这样，就像这样，他浑身湿透了，就好像……怎么回事？我懂，我懂这要说到哪儿去了。怎么回事？他说：“我掉进游泳池了。”我说：“你掉进游泳池了，怎么掉的？”原来当我们的女儿还小的时候，她以前挺喜欢让李假装把她扔进游泳池里的。
Sure, like swing her out over and then swing her back. Yes, swing her out over that swing her back. And he was like, I was doing the thing where I swing her over the swimming pool. But I lost my balance and I fell in. And I was like, is she okay? Did she fall in? He's like, she's fine. She's dry.
当然，就像把她荡出去然后又荡回来。对，把她荡出去然后又荡回来。他说：“我当时正在做那种把她荡到游泳池上方的动作。但我失去了平衡，然后我就掉进去了。”我说：“她没事吧？她掉进去了吗？”他说：“她没事。她是干的。”
Well, we have a security camera, Angela, and we went and we got the footage. It is so funny. We still sometimes play it as a family. You can see him like, thank swinging her over the pulley, swinging her, and then he's swinging her, and then he swings her,
好吧，安杰拉，我们有监控录像，我们去把录像调出来了。太搞笑了。我们有时还会作为家庭节目放来看。你可以看到他，像是，谢谢，把她荡到水池上方，荡着她，然后他荡着她，接着他把她荡出去，
and you see him start to lose his balance. And through some, like, you're're saying, like in these moments, what is your character? What is your instinct? Through some, like heroic feet, like the kind of thing you see football players do where they get both feet down before they fall out of bounds. Like you're like, how did they do it? He while falling into the pool whips
然后你看到他开始失去平衡。而凭借某种，就像你说的，在这些时刻，你的性格是什么？你的本能是什么？凭借某种英雄般的壮举——就像你在橄榄球运动员身上看到的那种，他们在摔出界外之前把双脚稳稳着地——你会想：“他们是怎么做到的？”他在掉进水池的同时，把
Our daughter around and places her gently on the side and then sort of falls backwards into the pool itself It's really incredible. He saved her while falling himself So I guess it's true, you know, in these moments, there's this instinctual part of you that just kicks in. Yeah. So I would hope my instinct would be to grab you knowing I might fall in with you, but to at least try. Yeah, but Jim does just the opposite. He leaned so far back, he's almost like, better you than me, you know? Yes.
我们的女儿顺势转过身，轻轻地把她放在池边，然后自己向后倒进水池里。这真的太不可思议了。他在自己摔倒的同时救了她。所以我想这是真的，你知道的，在这些时刻，你身上确实有一种本能的部分会被瞬间激发。对。所以我希望我的本能是抓住你，尽管我知道我可能会和你一起掉下去，但至少要尝试一下。对，但吉姆做的恰恰相反。他往后仰得那么多，感觉简直像是“死道友不死贫道”那种心态，你知道吗？对。
Yeah, could he have helped him? Should he have at least reached out? Was he maybe just surprised and thrown off guard? Because that could happen. You could just be so surprised in the moment. I thought John did a great body acting job there. Mm-hmm. I thought he really did a good job.
对，他本可以帮他吗？他至少本该伸手吗？或者他也许只是感到震惊而没有防备？因为那是有可能的。你在当时的那一刻可能只是太震惊了。我觉得约翰在那里的形体表演做得非常棒。嗯哼。我觉得他真的演得很出色。
Well, the episode ends with Pam asking Aaron to fact something for her, and she sees it as an opportunity to bring up Andy. And she says, isn't he, you know, great? And Aaron's like, Andy, is the coolest person I've ever met. Ooh, romance. I did catch a post at note. At 20 minutes, 47 seconds.
好吧，这一集的结尾是帕姆让艾伦帮她核对文件上的某事，她把这视为一个提及安迪的机会。她说：“他不挺……你知道的，挺棒的吗？”艾伦则说：“安迪啊？他是我见过的最酷的人。”哦，浪漫。我确实发现了一个便签。在20分47秒处。
Guys, does it say call mom? It says call mom and then something on the bottom I couldn't make out. That's weird. I know. Because Aaron has just shared she's an orphan. So what's the post atit note with Call Mom? Do you think Ellie needed to call her mom? I don't know.
伙计们，上面写的是“给妈妈打电话”吗？上面写着“给妈妈打电话”，下面还有一行我辨认不出来的内容。真奇怪。我知道。因为艾伦刚刚分享过她是个孤儿。那写着“给妈妈打电话”的便签是怎么回事？你觉得是艾莉需要给她妈妈打电话吗？我不知道。
Was it a post-it note to herself? Maybe it was. I used to do that. Oh, I know. I saw your grocery list. Well, guys, that's Koi Pond. It is, and we have some shout outs, some big thank yous to go over. Yes, thank you so much, Randy Cordray, for giving us the low down on how you built that Koi pond and how that all worked. And thank you to Warren and Halstead for your amazing behind-the-scenes facts and for your audio clips breaking down the real life event.
那是她留给自己的便签吗？也许是的。我以前经常那样做。哦，我懂，我看见过你的购物清单。好吧，伙计们，这就是《锦鲤池》。确实如此，我们有一些鸣谢，要向一些重要的大人物表示感谢。是的，非常感谢兰迪·科德雷，给我们详细介绍了你是如何建造那个锦鲤池以及这一切是如何运作的。还要感谢沃伦和霍尔斯塔德提供精彩的幕后花絮，以及剖析现实生活中事件的音频片段。
audio clips breaking down the real life event. We wanted to let you know that Hallstead is a producer on Central Park. It's an animated show and the second half of season two is going to premiere on Apple TV on March 4th. It is a fully animated musical starring Leslie Odom Jr. Catherine Han, Josh Gad, Titus Burgess, Emmy Raver Lattman, Kristen Bell, David Diggs, and Stanley Tucci. And I think I have to say a personal thank you to Warren, who just humored his ex-wife texting him a whole bunch about this episode. And I'd also like to say a big thank you to our friend Amy Weaver, now Amy Reid. She has written a feature called Smokey Mountain Rain, which she is also set to direct, Go Amy! Go Amy! Guys, we love you. We'll see you again next week. Yeah, because there's a double date with Jim and Pam and Michael and Pam's mom.
剖析现实生活中事件的音频片段。我们想让你们知道，霍尔斯塔德是《中央公园》的制片人。这是一部动画剧集，第二季的后半部分将于3月4日在Apple TV上首播。这是一部全动画音乐剧，由小莱斯利·奥多姆、凯瑟琳·汉恩、乔什·加德、蒂图斯·伯吉斯、艾米·拉维尔-兰普曼、克里斯汀·贝尔、戴维·迪格斯和斯坦利·图齐主演。我想我必须个人感谢一下沃伦，他只是幽默地应付了他前妻关于这一集给他发的一大堆短信。我还想对我们的朋友艾米·韦弗（现名艾米·里德）表示由衷的感谢。她写了一部名为《烟雾山之雨》的长片剧本，她也将亲自执导这部电影，加油，艾米！加油，艾米！伙计们，我们爱你们。我们下周再见。对，因为接下来是吉姆、帕姆和迈克尔与帕姆妈妈的四人约会。
Oh no. What could go wrong? We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Ear Wolf, Jennifer Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins.
哦，不。还会出什么岔子？我们下周见。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Ear Wolf、詹妮弗·费舍尔和安杰拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our sound engineer is Sam Keifer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Ratten. For add free versions of Office Ladies, go to stitur premium dot com. For a free one month trial at stitur premium use code office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是埃因斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问stitur premium点com。在stitur premium免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码office。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。